Und dieses Multipass TCP sei A noch relativ jung, wurde wohl angeblich wild bei diesem IETF-Meeting Jungs in Berlin diskutiert, wo du ja auch warst.
Da wird alles immer wild diskutiert und am Ende summen sie immer alle.
Summen?
Nee, das ist so, dass die machen Zustimmung per Akklamation, aber nicht durch Getrampel oder Tischgeklopfer, es gibt nämlich keine Tische, sondern die Leute summen immer alle. Was? Wir haben jetzt hier einen Vorschlag und wollen wir das jetzt beschließen oder so? Und alle Leute, die dafür sind, sollen jetzt mal hummen und dann machen die alle so...
Tolles Verfahren.
Das ist ja echt interessant. Können wir ja auch mal probieren oder? Göppelt euch Leiche. Ja, gefällt. Mir gefällt alles. Ich bin positiv.
Tranking, wir waren bei der Fritzbox. Bei SIPgate kannst du dir einen 2-Kanal Tranking kostenlos geben lassen. Hier steht testen sie kostenlos. Ich nehme mal an, dass es dann auch für immer kostenlos ist. Und wenn du so ein 10er-Rufnummer-Block haben willst, wie ich das gerne hätte, muss man 5er abdrücken im Monat.
Genau, 3-Rufnummer, 10er-Rufnummer-Block, 100er-Rufnummer-Block, 15 Euro, dann kannst du richtig Spaß haben. Aber Rufnummer-Block heißt jetzt nicht, dass du jetzt 3 wilde Rufnummern hast, so wie früher, oder 10 wilde Rufnummern, sondern 10er-Rufnummer-Block heißt einfach, dass du jetzt vielleicht, ich nehme mal an, in Berlin werden sie eine 9-stellige Nummer in den Fall geben oder so was, und die letzte Ziffer ist denn deine. Ja, 9 oder 10, ich müsste mal ausprobieren. Und was sie da so anbieten, dann können wir mal gucken, ob die hier schon alle rufen und anbieten.
Ist doch super, kann man endlich mal schön einführen. Fax!
Gibt es übrigens auch noch von anderen, kannst du dann mal gucken, wenn man hier schon wilde Werbung machen, kannst du nochmal bei PlaZTel gucken, also mit C, PLA, PLTL, Placetel.
Ja, da kenne ich auch Leute, die von SIP Gate dahin gewechselt sind.
Es gibt auch unsere Freunde hier, von Internet in Berlin, das findest du nicht auf der Webseite, aber die haben auch so SIP-Trunks. Also es gibt alle Leute, die ein bisschen SIP machen, kennen dieses Spiel auch. Diese Anlagenanschlüsse ist immer was, das wird immer so genommen, das ist was für Profis. Das gibt man nicht dem Bastler für seine Fritzbox zu Hause. Wobei es jetzt technischer geht, die Fritzbox kann das ja jetzt nur. Aber das war immer so ein, genauso wie zum Beispiel ISDN-Anlagenanschlüsse, da musst du bei der Telekom auf der Webseite auch ganz schön rumklicken. Gibt es auch immer noch, sitzt aber halt eben nicht vorne drauf.
Aber was hat sich denn da überhaupt geändert vom Protokoll her, dass man das jetzt so, so schwierig ist das zu unterstützen?
Das Protokoll ist das selbe, du musst das halt nur vorher wissen. Und man hat, naja, wenn jetzt wissen wir jetzt, ein Problem ist mit dieser Signalisierung bei SIP immer gewesen, dass der Standard oder die Leute, die das erfunden haben, haben gesagt, wir machen jetzt mal richtig Internet-Telefonie. Die haben davon geträumt, dass man jemanden anders anruft, indem man bla.fasel.com eingibt als Adresse und nicht Telefonnummern. Also sozusagen, dass man mit SIP-IDs arbeitet, diese aussehen wie so E-Mail-Adressen zum Beispiel. Das war mal deren Traum, dass man endlich diese Rufnummern-Geschichte überkommt. Das geht aber auch. Ja, das geht ja auch noch. So ist der Standard ja auch gebaut. Diese ganze Rufnummern-Geschichte hat man dann hinterher drauf gesetzt, weil es ein paar Leute gab, die es wieder rummollen mussten und sagen ja, aber das ist doch blöd, wenn ich nur Leute mit so einer SIP-ID anrufen kann. Ich will ja auch noch normale Leute anrufen mit einer Telefonnummer. Und dann haben die so ein bisschen mit den Zähnen geknirscht und haben gesagt ok, dann denken wir uns jetzt was aus, wie wir das machen, wenn man da normale Telefonnummern reinmacht. Und diese Standardisierung ist leider nicht komplett zu Ende geführt worden. Komplett zu Ende geführt wurde für mich heißen, dass ganz klar ist, was steht da für Rufnummer drin. Steht da komplette E164-Rufnummer drin, d.h. mit Landeskennung, Ortsnetzkennung usw. Oder denkt sich da jeder seinen Scheiß aus. Und dieses Problem haben wir bis heute. Dass diese Rufnummer-Geschichte dort, das siehst du auch bei den verschiedenen SIP-Anbietern, musst du immer genau nachgucken. Wenn die dir eine Rufnummer schicken, wie schicken sie dir? Schicken sie dir eine eigentliche Nummer mit 030 vorne dran? Oder schicken sie dir 4930? Oder schicken sie dir 004930? Das macht jeder, wie er lustig ist. Das hat natürlich für einen wahnsinnigen Hickhack gesorgt, dass in der Anfangszeit von diesem ganzen SIP-Quatsch wahnsinnig viele Interoperabilitätsprobleme gab allein schon durch diese Geschichte. Was die Leute gemacht haben, ist, um sich das zu vereinfachen, haben sie gesagt, du musst dich ja eh registrieren drüben. Das heißt, es gibt so eine Art Authentication Procedure, wo so ein SIP-Client sich bei seinem Provider, ob das nun jemand ist wie Zipgate oder deine Fritzbox auch immer, anmeldet. Und man ist inzwischen dazu übergegangen, um den User nicht mit diesen Details zu überfrachten, dass man einfach diese signalisierten Rufnummern mehr oder weniger ignoriert. Natürlich nicht die gewählte Rufnummer, aber so die eigene Rufnummer. Das führt also dazu, dass man jetzt sagt, im Normalfall eine SIP-Kennung, das heißt ein Login, gleich ein User, gleich eine Rufnummer. Und daher kommt das bei den ganzen Standardsachen, die man so macht, hast du halt immer pro Login eine Rufnummer drauf. Was man jetzt macht bei diesem SIP-Trunking, da ist jetzt noch mal der Versuch, noch mal richtig hinzugehen, zu sagen, wir machen das noch mal so, wie es gedacht ist, wir haben einen Login und über diesen einen Login wickeln wir mehrere Rufnummer ab, indem wir die richtig signalisieren und der Empfänger muss halt eben diesmal richtig in die Header reingucken, muss dekodieren und sagen, diesmal ist die Durchwahl 42 angerufen worden, mach ich was anderes, als wenn die Durchwahl 23 angerufen wurden. Diese SIP-Zeug ist ein Zoo. Es ist wirklich ein Zoo, es ist ein Interoperabilitäts-Zoo. Es hat sich in den letzten Jahren stabilisiert, aber es ist wirklich, wenn man sich damit näher befasst, es ist zum Haare raufen. Und deswegen verwende ich zum Beispiel sehr gerne Produkte, wo ich möglichst viel Einfluss draufnehmen kann und die ganzen Rufnummern umformatieren kann und normieren kann und so weiter und so fort. Weil das ist wirklich echt krass. Und zwar gibt es ja jede Menge Rufnummern. Es gibt ja die Rufnummer, die dich anruft. Es gibt die Rufnummer, die du anrufst. Es gibt die weiterleitende Rufnummer. Es gibt die Rufnummer, die dargestellt werden soll. Wir kennen ja alle das Problem, dass man schon seit Jahren Rufnummern faken kann beim Anrufen. Das gab es auch schon vor SIP-Zeiten. Aber bei SIP, es gibt sehr viele SIP-Provider, die dir erlauben, deine eigene Rufnummer mitzubermitteln. Das heißt, du sagst selber an bei deinem Call, welche Rufnummer der Angerufene sehen soll. Auf seinem Handy oder auf seinem ISTN-Telefon. Diese Signalisierung auch richtig hinzukriegen, dass jetzt nicht irgendein Scheiß drinsteht, ist halt eben auch immer noch so ein bisschen so ein Kniffel. Das geht alles, aber das ist ein echter Zoo.
Das ist ganz wild. Das heißt, es ist ein sinnvolles Update hier für die Fritz-Borgs. Das ist nur für die Große, nur für die 7390, nur für das Flaggschiff und diese Neueherde.
AVM hat immer so ein bisschen darauf, dass sie ihr Labor nur so für ein, zwei Kisten macht, für ihre neuesten Kisten. Also 7390, 7490. Und wenn das jetzt released, kommt das innerhalb von wenigen Wochen für die anderen Kisten nach. Ich meine, SIP-Trunk ist jetzt nur eins von den Features. Sie haben jetzt die ganze VPN-Sache viel schöner gemacht. Man musste bisher, wenn man VPNs konfigurieren will, musste man sich so eine super tolle, geile DOS-Windows-Software runterladen. Sich mit dieser Windows-Software eine Konfiguration zusammenklicken, die man dann per Browser-Upload in die Fritzbox reinlädt. Das war immer ein bisschen krank. Das haben sie jetzt alles in ihr Web-Interface reingemacht. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt diese Feature wie ich möchte gerne einen VPN von meinem iPhone in meinem Heimnetz haben, kannst du jetzt komplett auf der Fritzbox zusammenklicken. Sie haben den Gastzugang nochmal deutlich besser gemacht und schöner gemacht. Also dass man ein zweites WLAN aufmachen kann, wo man Gäste reinlassen kann. Die kann man dann auch einschränken zeitlich oder kann sagen, die dürfen nur surfen und E-Mail lesen. Was das jetzt auch wieder soll, weiß ich nicht. Aber weißt du, solche Geschichten, das ist echt krass Leute, die sowas immer machen. Aber ja, jedenfalls solche Späßgänge können sie machen. Was übrigens auch sehr schick ist, finde ich, dass sie jetzt mal so ein paar Standards aufgegriffen haben. Ihr kennt ja alle QR-Codes und ihr wisst ja auch, dass man mit QR-Codes alle möglichen anderen Scheiß machen kann. Wie All-Star sieht man jetzt an jeder Bushaltestelle. Das ist ja auf jedem Werbeplakat, da ist ja ein QR-Code drauf. Das gibt auch Leute, die schon erkannt haben, dass man Visitenkarten machen kann. Aber man kann damit sogar WLANs konfigurieren. Es gibt ein URI-Schem für QR-Codes, wo man die kompletten WLAN-Daten rein machen kann. Also wie heißt das WLAN und wie ist der WPA-Schlüssel dafür? Das kann man in einen QR-Code rein machen, was ich relativ sexy finde. Und das unterstützt die Fritzbox auch. Das heißt, die generiert dir dann so einen QR-Code, den kannst du dir ausdrucken, an die Wand hängen. Und wenn denn dein Gast kommt mit seinem Android-Phone, zeigst du einfach auf diesen QR-Code, er fotografiert ihn ab mit seinem Android-Phone und pups, ist er drin in deinem WLAN.
Das ist geil, bei Android hast du dann auch gleich den aktuellen Exploit dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie mit drin. Und dann so, ja, WLAN willst du haben, dann zack, bumma, ist das Ding gerutet.
Aber, äh...
Nicht die Android-Leute, die schimpfen dann wieder.
Jaja, dann gibt's wieder Ärger. Nee, auf dem iPhone, mein QR-Reder auf dem iPhone liest das auch, aber dadurch, dass der ja nicht ran darf an die WLAN-Daten, äh... zeigt er sie mir bloß an und dann muss ich sie mit Cut und Paste da rausnehmen und dann übernehmen. Aber immerhin, das ist ja nun nicht, ist ja nun mein iPhone-Problem. Aber immerhin solche Sachen unterstützt AVM jetzt auch mit der neuen Firma, das finde ich eigentlich ganz niedlich. Und noch tausend und drei andere kleine Verbesserungen. V6, äh... haben sie sehr viel gemacht. Ähm, witzigerweise, ich hätte es echt nicht erwartet, muss ich jetzt mal kurz erwähnen, seit 3, 4 Wochen oder so weit haben mich mehrere Leute kontaktiert, die intensiv V6 benutzen mit ihrer Fritzbox, auch aus dem Außenlande, auch etlicher und die jetzt gefragt haben, was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt dahinter noch einen Router anbringe? Also die ihr Netz hinter ihrer Fritzbox noch mal, noch mal weiter unterteilen. Das mache ich übrigens auch. Ich hab's jetzt hier noch mal ein bisschen näher dokumentiert gerade neug für jemanden. Und die Mechanismen, die in V6 dafür vorgesehen sind, nämlich die sogenannte prefix delegation, hat AVM auch brav implementiert. Das heißt, du kannst hingehen, wenn in einer idealen Welt hast du einen ISP, der der V6 nativ gibt, wie zum Beispiel die Telekom, deinen neuen DSL-Anschluss von der Telekom, nimmst mit der Volt-Option, dann kommt dir da richtig normales V6 raus. Du kommst zwar nicht zu Ackermai bis vor einer Woche, aber vom Prinzip kommt es da erst mal raus. Und die Fritzbox nimmt das verteilt in dein Netz. Wenn du jetzt einen Router nimmst, den du hinter deine Fritzbox setzt, weil du jetzt vielleicht nochmal einen WG hast und jedem sein eigenes Netz geben willst, oder bei einer kleinen Firma bist, die noch untere Netze hat, also einzelne Netze für einzelne Abteilungen, dann geht dieser zweite Router hinten hin und sagt Hallo Fritzbox, ich brauch mal noch weitere V6-Adressen von dir, ich brauch mal noch Subnetze. Und die Fritzbox teilt die dann zu und der Router teilt die nach hinten weiter zu. Das funktioniert alles, wenn man das einmal sagt, ich will das so, geht das automatisch. Und das finde ich schon ziemlich sexy. Das haben die jetzt mal richtig ordentlich durchimplementiert. Das hat dann sogar den Effekt, dass wenn die Telekom dir mal dein V6-Präfix ändert, ändert der sich komplett durch. Das rattert durch durch deine Fritzbox bis auf den hinteren Router und ändert alle Subnetze automatisch, so wie sich die Erdenker von IPv6 mal gedacht haben. Und das ist jetzt mal ordentlich implementiert in einem Konsumentengerät, nämlich einer Fritzbox, die man einfach am Saturn kaufen kann. Und das finde ich jetzt für mich schon mal ist das schon mal ein kleiner Reisepartei.
Also, the founders of the internet have approved this message.
Also, alle 24 Stunden wieder Zwangsttrennung jetzt auch mit neuer IPv6-Adresse?
Nee, es wird nicht. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Wenn du so einen tollen DSL-Anschluss von der Telekom hast mit V6 und Volp, dann wird der nicht mehr zwangsgetrennt. Aber wenn du den trennst, wenn zum Beispiel nach dem Stromausfall, wie immer du deine Fritzbox bootest, dann kriegst du eine neue Adresse und einen neuen Präfix. Aber die Telekom trennt dir den glaube ich nur noch einmal alle sechs Monate. Das steht noch drin, dass sie das noch machen. Wenn du das nicht bis dahin geschafft hast, das von dir aus mal zu killen, das Ding. Aber ansonsten fällt das weg und du behältst dann auch deine V4-Adresse so lange, wie das Ding da ist.
Oder wenn es nicht Vattenfall geschafft hat.
Oder wer auch immer. Aber diese tägliche Zwangstrennung fällt dabei auch weg.
Ich mache jetzt gerade aktive IPv6. Wie soll ich sagen? Ich betreibe den Netzausbau voran in allen Cafés, in denen ich so regelmäßig verweile. Ich stelle das jetzt als Bedingung, dass wenn ich da regelmäßig Kaffee trinke, dass sie dann auch mindestens mal 6-4 anklicken. Weil das ein bisschen anstrengend ist, jedes Mal seinen Tunnel aufzumachen.
Ich mache das auch. Ich mache Beratungen für alle möglichen Leute und Organisationen. Wenn ich jetzt Netze baue, seit etlichen Jahren, ich baue immer V6-Netze primär. Wenn die dann ein bisschen rumweinen, sagen sie wollen immer noch V4 haben, dann kriegen sie meinetwegen auch noch V4. Aber primär baue ich immer erst mal ein V6-Netz. Das betrifft jetzt zum Beispiel das Management. Wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Switch oder irgendwas einbaue, dann hat die eine Management-Adresse, über die man mit ihm reden kann. Da fange ich gar nicht erst an, mich mit irgendeinem Admin zu unterhalten, nach dem Motto, gib mir mal eine V4-Adresse. Ich hab keinen Bock, mich mit dem zu streiten, dass der mir sagt, er hat gar keinen Adressraum dafür. Wieso braucht ein Switch eine IP-Adresse? Ich mach einfach V6 an und dann ist Ruhe. Deswegen baue ich diese Dinger so, dass die erst mal V6 können, dass das alles toll ist. Und wenn dann noch Zeit ist oder die User rumjammern, dann kriegen sie noch V4, was in der Regel bedeutet wieder, dass man so Nutt und sowas aufsetzen muss und sich mit dem ganzen Scheiß darum ärgern muss, der da mitkommt. Mach ich dann auch, aber primär mach ich es erstmal so, dass es schick ist. Und dann kann man es ja immer noch ein bisschen... Ja, das V4 selber ist gar nicht so schlimm. Aber Nutt ist schlimm. Und alles, was danach kommt.
Ja, aber es ist ja sozusagen 80er-Jahre Technologie. Also wir können ja nochmal ein paar 80er-Jahre Songs einspielen. Dann merkt man eigentlich, wie unangemessen das ist.
Aber früher 80er, die klingen fast noch so wie 70er.
Gut, also Fritzbox Update empfohlen.
So ein USB... Ich sag Donald Fetish. Ich meine, ich hab hier vier Stück in der Hand.
Das ist meine vierschwänzige Peilche. Mit den Ethernet Doggles werden hier die Leute ausgepeilt, die nur IPv4 haben.
Kannst du die übrigens alle reinstecken über einen Hub, dann kannst du endlich mal deinen Mac zu einem Router machen. Dann hast du genug Ethernet Interfaces. Das geht sogar ganz gut. Übrigens, wer damit mal spielen will, man kann den zum Router oder zur Bridge machen oder so. Ja, und dann hast du halt bis 100 Mega betroffen.
Aber das ist wirklich cool, mehrere dabei haben, damit kann man dann diese Routing-Probleme in Hotels und Bereitstellungen und Durchtunneln von irgendwelchen bekloppten WLANs und so weiter. Manchmal hat man einfach nicht genug Ethernet Interfaces, um das zu machen, was man machen will, und dann ist das ganz gut. Du machst dich nicht kaputt, Dennis.
Gibt es nicht auch einen USB-Teil, wo gleich mehrere rauskommen?
Sieben gibt es dann. Das ist die siebenschwänzige Ethernet-Peitsche.
Aber einmal USB und mehrere Ethernet-Ports?
Ja, gab es mal. Ist aber teurer, als wenn du einen Hub-Kurs unter sieben von den Dingern reinsteckst. Ich verstehe. Übrigens weiterleiten, da muss man nochmal ein bisschen, weiß jetzt nicht, ob man Apple dafür hauen sollte oder nicht. Mich hat neulich mal ein verzweifelter User kontaktiert, der ist irgendwie, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, Gaststudent an irgendeiner ausländischen Uni. Die haben ihr Netz so gebaut, wie sich das gehört, nämlich mit einer richtigen Authentication. Also 832.nsx, da kannst du dich nicht einfach aufs Ethernet draufstecken, sondern musst erstmal ein Usernamen-Passwort da eintippern. Was ja auch Sinn macht, weil immer, da wo noch Kabel-Ethernet gibt, ist natürlich die Verleitung hoch, dass man einfach hingeht, sich da drauf steckt und dann Spaß hat. Und die Leute, die ihr Netz ein bisschen ordentlich verwalten, machen das schon seit Längerem so, dass sie im Switch sagen, ne, jemand der sich da drauf steckt, der muss sich erstmal authentizieren, sonst gibt's da keine Bits. Und der ist halt in so einer Situation, der wollte nur noch sein iPhone betreiben und so. Und da gibt's halt irgendwie keinen WLAN. Und dann hat er sich gedacht, na, er macht mal diese tolle Internet-Sharing von seinem Mac. Das heißt, er steckt das Kabelrennen in seinen Mac. Er hat ja eine Kennung von der Uni, ja, gibt da seinen Username und Passwort ein und macht dann sein Internet-Sharing an und dann wird alles gut. Aber Apple ist dann stur und geht dann hin und sagt, ne, ich habe hier eine Verbindung nach draußen mit 802.1x Authentication, die schere ich nicht.
Nein.
Das ist natürlich schön aus Sicht, das sagt das echt aktiv, das sagt nicht, dass es nicht einfach nicht geht, sondern macht dann so, nö, das will ich nicht. Und jetzt muss man natürlich sagen, wenn das Gerät und das Betriebssystem, wie bei Windows in der Regel dem Admin gehört, würde ich sagen, okay, der will das so und ist okay. Aber Apple ist normalerweise eigentlich eher so auf der Konsumentenseite, dachte ich bisher immer. Das heißt also, das ist mein Mac und ich möchte gerne das tun, was ich will und nicht das, was irgendein Netzwerk-Admin tut.
Ja, das ist das Netzwerk.
Und warum macht der Mac, den ich für ein scheiß Geld kaufe, den ich für ein scheiß Geld kaufe, eben voraus einen gehorsamen Watt, was glaubt, was der Admin von mir will? Nämlich das Netzwerk nicht weiterscheren. Ja, aber das machen die eben voraus einen gehorsamen. Das ist der Punkt, den ich ärgere. Das ist mein Gerät, mein OS, ich bin Admin dort und du sollst das verdammt noch mal scheren. Der weiß auch genau, was ich von ihm will, aber er sagt, ne, das tue ich nicht. Weil, das durfst du nicht. Woher wissen der das? Er nimmt das halt immer einfach an, aber das zeigt so ein bisschen die Tendenz. Das war wie gesagt früher bei den Windows-Kisten, die über den zentralen Domain-Controller administriert werden, wo alles immer zugeknipst wird, dass der User das ja nicht anfasst und so. Das kann ich alles verstehen. Aber eigentlich war das bei Apple früher nicht so. Und jetzt machen die sowas auch. Und das finde ich jetzt irgendwie blöd.
Tja, mit Steve hätte es das nicht gegeben. Ja, Insightful würde ich sagen. Ich habe alles geupdatet, was bei mir hier auf das neue OS gehen kann, mit der Fritzbox. Das kann man auf jeden Fall empfehlen. Das scheint zu funktionieren.
Es hat noch ein paar ganz kleine Wanzen drin, aber die merkt nicht jeder.
Wir nehmen jetzt auch gleich nochmal Mavericks auseinander, würde ich sagen. Oder? Ich meine, wir hatten ja jetzt diverse Apple-Ereignisse, wollen wir uns jetzt erstmal dem Mavericks Release The Bad and the Ugly zu wenden.
Wenn du der Meinung bist, da gibt es noch groß was zu reden.
Ja, naja, es gibt Erfahrung jetzt. Ich meine, bisher gab es ja immer nur viel Prerelease-Gemunkel. Letztes Mal haben wir ein bisschen da in diesem Prerelease rumgemuckelt. Aber wenn man das dann erstmal so auf richtige Real-World-Maschinen loslässt, dann kommt man ja überhaupt erstmal so auf, wie es wirklich funktioniert.
Also bei mir ist alles super.
Können wir beim Installer erstmal loslegen, oder? Also ich hab das auf meinem MacBook installiert, ich hab auf dem Mac Pro installiert, ich hab's auf dem alten 2008er Mac Pro installiert. Der ist ja schon doch einer der älteren Geräte, die Mavericks unterstützt. Und es ging überall einwandfrei, kein Ärger, kein Mucken. Hier gerade auf meinem Laptop poppt ein Fenster auf. Also ich hab schon Mavericks drauf, der Kiste. Und da meinte, ich müsste jetzt mal Mavericks installieren. Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil ich vorher den GM drauf hatte. Und die hat noch eine kleine Änderung danach geschrieben. Und das kam gerade während der Sendung.
Bei mir war das auch so. Die haben irgendwas kaputt gemacht. Aber das kann vielleicht auch am ersten GM liegen. Mit den Downloads, das hatte ich in iTunes, dass er mir die Keynote von Apple, den ich als Podcast abonniert hab, mehrmals runtergeladen hat. Also vier oder fünf Mal, bevor ich das irgendwie gekillt hab. Und der App Store hat mir auch das Mavericks mehrmals runtergeladen und dann ist es irgendwie aufgepoppt. Keine Ahnung. Ich hab dann den Installer ganz runtergeschmissen und dann hörte das auf.
Und der hat dann durchgedreht sozusagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Public API ist, aber ich glaube, die haben den Download-Service so schon auch, ja.
Ich glaube ganz so einfach nicht, dass da einfach nur ein so ein Call nicht funktioniert, weil da muss ja schon noch ein bisschen mehr Logik sein. Ist jetzt nicht so, dass der Call auch das Ding da ablegt und dann auch noch dafür sorgt, dass das irgendwie gesehen wird und der Installer hochpoppt und sagt, du müsstest jetzt mal wieder Mavericks installieren. Also ich glaube, da ist nicht nur ein defekter Call für zuständig.
Ja, aber bei iTunes war das besonders bekloppt, weil ich dann habe ich angefangen, diese Keynote zu gucken und bin bis zur Hälfte gekommen und habe dann irgendwie, hat er abgebrochen und mir gesagt, ah, er hat jetzt runtergeladen und war wieder am Anfang. Dann habe ich wieder geguckt und dann passiert das nochmal.
Das war bei dir aber auch alles die GM, oder? Das war auch alles mit der GM.
Jaja, ich habe immer noch die GM drauf. Vielleicht sollte ich tatsächlich mal...
Kommt kein Fenster und sagt, du musst mal Mavericks installieren bisher?
Nee, ich hatte dieses Problem mit dem, ja, können wir gleich rein schmeißen, noch mit in die Kiste, mit dem iWorks, weil ich das iWorks 09 drauf hatte.
Lass uns aber erstmal bei der Installation bleiben, da habe ich auch noch was hinzuzufügen.
Nee, aber das ist halt diese Download-Sache mit dem iWorks 09, wo du nur dann das Update angeboten bekommst, wenn du deinen Mavericks auf Englisch fährst. Wenn du es auf Deutsch fährst, kriegst du das Update nicht angeboten. Ach. Also als kleiner Tipp da draußen, wenn ihr noch nicht geupdatet habt und ihr wollt noch updaten, dann ja.
Das ist dieser Alltagsrassismus unter OSX. Das ist schlimm.
Nee, ich glaub, das ist einfach der American Saucer Cup Rim. Also das ist so...
Der Wasch? Der Wasch?
American Saucer Cup Rim.
Saucer Cup Rim?
Ja, der Untertassenrand. Der amerikanische.
Verstehe.
Hast du eigentlich auch Eis bestellt?
Oh ja, stimmt.
Eis.
Den Hinblick müsstet ihr sehen. Jetzt? Wir haben auch Schokolade.
Ja, aber die sieht nicht so gut aus.
Doch, ich finde, die sieht sehr gut aus.
Zeig noch mal richtig.
Lindschokolade ist von einem Hörer persönlich herangetragen worden.
Maxi-Pleisir.
Maxi-Pleisir. Ich meine, Maxi-Pleisir.
Entschuldigung, aber Maxi-Pleisir.
Max tut uns leid, du kriegst nix, Clemens.
Maxi-Pleisir klingt schon so ein bisschen nach Kondom, finde ich.
Clemens hört uns jetzt wieder gerade nicht, hat sich schon wieder irgendwie disconnected. Maxi-Pleisir. Also ich meine, Maxi-Pleisir, ja oder nein? Also das ja, ne? Aber du frisst auch noch Eis, denn es ist für alles gesorgt. Hier bleibt kein Auge trocken und jeder Zuckerbedarf wird hier gestillt. Hier gibt es auch extra große Einheiten, sehe ich gerade. Ich mach das hier mal auf. Nachdem wir jetzt hier so viel on Topic machen, können wir auch, glaube ich, hier mal so ein bisschen wieder in unser gewohntes Chaos einmünden. Clemens hat sich mal wieder abgeschaltet.
Dann erzähl doch mal hier bald noch deine Installationsgeschichten.
Jaja, wollte ich auch gerade, wenn ihr mit euren Installationsgeschichten fertig seid.
Nee, es war nur das, dass der Installer erstmal ein bisschen Chaos erzeugt hat. Und mir zwar angezeigt hat, ich hab fünf Updates, aber hab dann oben, bei Dennis sieht man das gerade so schön, oben nur so eine Leiste, wo nichts drinsteht. Dann denkst du so, ne?
Ja, hab ich aber immer noch, obwohl ich jetzt drüber installiert hab. Also irgendwie ist das noch ein bisschen komisch.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Irgendwann wird dann was angezeigt. Dann wollte Anna updaten. Dann hab ich erst mal Anna updaten.
Der Trick ist übrigens für Leute, die den auch nicht bekommen, den das updaten. Man kann auch ins Terminal gehen, Software Update sagen. Heißt das Software Update? Ja, Software Update, minus L, minus A. Dann sieht man alle Updates, die so da sind.
Ich kann auch gleich sagen, minus I, dann installiert das ja auch gleich.
Erst mal gucken, nicht blind installieren. Erst mal gucken. Und genau.
Jetzt wieder für alles gesorgt.
Hattest du gar kein Eis?
Doch. Na das war doch für ihn.
Du hast keins bestellt.
Du hast keins hingeschrieben.
Das ist das, was mir letztes Mal passiert ist.
Du hast nur gesagt, die gleiche Pizza wie Dennis.
Nee, ich hab gesagt wie Dennis. Das ist nicht halt jetzt Schokolade, das ist übrigens sehr gut.
Ja genau, die Schokolade ist super, sei zufrieden. Installieren, ja. Also ich muss auch sagen, das ist schon seit langem mal wieder ein OS X Release, was ich mit Freuden binnen kürzester Zeit auf alle Maschinen verteilt habe.
Mit Freuden mach ich immer alles vorher, aber wie es danach aussieht.
Nee, es war nicht immer mit Freude in den letzten Jahren.
Weil du schon vorher wusstest, dass das scheiße ist?
Weil ich es schon geahnt hab.
Bei Mavericks hast du es nicht geahnt.
Bei Mavericks hab ich früh geahnt, dass es nicht so scheiße ist.
Ja, aber ist es denn scheiße? Weißt du doch gar nicht, oder doch?
Also es ist sicherlich nicht noch nicht alles im grünen Bereich bei Mavericks, aber es ist auf jeden Fall viel Gutes dabei. Also ich bin sehr angetan von diesem Release auf sehr vielen Ebenen, weil ich finde, sie haben endlich mal wieder ein paar Sachen richtig gut hinbekommen. Zur Installation, ich hab einen Fehler gemacht. Ich hab das hier auf meinem Mac Pro installiert und dann war er schon fast fertig. Man ist ja immer so gelangweilt, wenn man vor solchen Installations-Screens sitzt. Und ich wollte so, ahhh, und dann spielt man immer so ein bisschen mit rum und dann konnte man ja immer so in den Menüs ein bisschen rumklicken.
Ich mach immer den Logger mit an, dieses älteste Zuguck, weil da irgendwie was passiert.
Ja genau, und da passiert dann irgendwie nichts und dann war ich so ein bisschen gelangweilt. Und dann bin ich durch die Menüs so durchgefuhrwerkt und... was macht ihr denn da, ihr kleinen Schmatzer? Genau, macht mal eure Mikrofone aus. Ja genau, nicht schmatzen. So und dann hab ich den Fehler gemacht und hab dieses Startup-Disc-Programm aufgerufen. Das kann man nämlich von da aus abrufen. Ich dachte ja nicht, dass ihn das irgendwie aus dem Tritt bringt, aber das brachte ihn wirklich aus dem Tritt. Hab das dann zwar wieder gleich gequittet, aber dann, weiß ich nicht, ging irgendwie nichts voran und dann blieb er ewig stehen und es war schlimm und dann bootet sich der und dann war er nicht zu Ende emigriert und dann musste ich jetzt wieder Backup einspielen und das machen. Aber ja, das war eine Kleinigkeit. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, wenn sie was dagegen haben, dass man dieses Programm von diesem Menü aus aufruft zu diesem Zeitpunkt, warum erlauben sie es dann überhaupt? Ich glaub nicht, dass jetzt viele Leute in solche Probleme reinlaufen. Naja.
Vor allen Dingen hat es der Tester nicht gemerkt.
Na gut, aber ich hab ja Backup eingespielt und ich kann an dieser Stelle auch nochmal bewerben. Carbon Copycloner ist wirklich ein geiles Tool. Das ist mittlerweile... Also man kann das zwar kostenlos benutzen, aber es möchte gerne gekauft werden. Aber es ist ein geiles Tool für so Backups, die danach auch funktionieren. Also der Typ, dieser Bombitch Software da, der hat einfach so viel Energie da reingelegt, das wirklich richtig zu machen. Mit allen Permissions und der weiß da einfach, was er tut und er kann auch diese Recovery Partitionen immer wieder ordentlich herstellen und so. Das ist einfach ein geiles Tool.
Time Machine Backup ist aber auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, aber Time Machine Backup liefert dir halt nicht mal eben eine bootbare Kopie. Du kannst halt mit CCC wirklich problemlos auf einem beliebigen Target eine bootbare Kopie erzeugen und von der dann zur Not auch gleich hochbooten, wenn irgendwas schief gegangen ist und du hast dann halt deinen eigenen Scheiß. Das ist wirklich sehr hilfreich gewesen, auch in diesem Prozess. Und ja, fand ich gut. Ich hatte dann hier noch diversen Ärger mit so komischen USB-Festplattengehäusen, die ein bisschen rumgezickt haben und dann hat dann die Installation dann abgebrochen, aber das habe ich dann letztlich auf die Hardware zurückführen können. Mavericks an sich, super. Ja, dann habe ich mal ein paar Sachen getestet. Als allererstes habe ich es auf dem alten 2008er iMac mit 6 GB RAM installiert. Da war so Mountain Line eher so meh. Insbesondere weil dieser Safari 6... Rest in Peace, du alte Sau! Also wirklich, keiner vermisst dich. Weil es ist einfach unfassbar, wenn du dir den RAM-Bedarf jetzt anschaust, mit dem neuen Safari und dem alten, das Tag und Nacht, dazu kommt halt, dass diese Aufteilung von Safari 7 das endlich jetzt mal so zu machen, wie Chromus schon immer gemacht hat, nämlich jede Seite in seinen eigenen Prozess, das führt zu deutlich mehr Performance und deutlich mehr Stabilität. Immer mal wieder passiert, dass einer festgehangen ist, aber dann war es halt nur die eine Seite, die ich laden musste und nicht alle 30 Tabs, die gerade rum lagen.
Also ich muss sagen, dass Safari mir eigentlich relativ selten abstürzt. Und jetzt Mavericks hab ich seit einer Woche und ich glaube, es ist jetzt schon vier oder fünf Mal, wo denn dieser Streifen kommt, ja hier der Prozess ist abgekackt und ich hab die Seite mal neu geladen.
Echt, das ist mir noch gar nicht passiert. Allerdings hab ich ein paar Mal schon einfach einen Tab aus dem Aktivitätsmenü einfach gesehen. Da läuft einer Amok, den schieß ich einfach ab, scheißegal was es ist. Und dann ist halt der Tab weg und Safari läuft aber weiter. Das fand ich schon ganz schick. Tabkilling.
Ja, das ist gut. Also das ist schon alles sehr sinnvoll. Und ich hab den Eindruck, dass dieses Compressed Memory Feature aber immer so richtig durchschlägt. Auf diesem Mac war ich eigentlich nach Starten von Safari und zwei, drei anderen Programmen war Memory immer voll. Ja, und ob da noch was lief, das hing im Wesentlichen von Safari ab. Jetzt mit Mavericks halb voll. Ich hab einfach doppelt so viel Speicher. Es ist wirklich wie RAM-Doubler in den 90ern.
Jaja, es funktioniert wirklich gut. Und dann guckt man rein und dann ist, weiß ich nicht, wie viel Gigabyte ist dann irgendwie komprimiert aber keine Swap-Datei.
Genau, da saur doch mal einer was über die RAM-Upgrade-Praise von Apple.
Also ich hab hier 8 Gigabyte in meinem Mac Pro und bisher hatte ich da gerade mal 300 komprimiert oder so. Und ich hab ja auch immer Xcode an und Zeug und so weiter. Also irgendwie 8 ist wohl ganz okay. Die 6 waren schon zu wenig. Aber du hast ja immer 1000 Sachen an.
Ich glaub 6 ist so ein bisschen die Grenze und ich frage mich halt, wie Leute das machen, die nur 4 Gigabyte RAM in ihrem Rechner haben und da auch nicht mehr reinkriegen.
Es geht auch noch schlimmer. Ich hab ja noch diesen uralt Mac Mini aus dem Jahre 2007. In den kann man mit Biegen und Brechen 3 Gigabyte Speicher reintun. Das reicht, um unter VM-Ware aber da läuft kein Mavericks. einen Mavericks laufen zu lassen, das dann 2 Gigabyte Speicher hat.
Was auf dem Rechner selber kannst du keinen Mavericks laufen lassen, aber auf dem VM-Ware.
Ja.
Wie pervers ist das denn?
Hätte man nicht aufgepasst. Da war der Sensor pinkeln.
Nee, das liegt daran, dass die Hardware so alt ist, dass es dafür keinen 64-Bit-Grafikkartentreiber gibt. Und die VM hat den aber. Deswegen konnte auch schon kein Mountain Lion drauflaufen. Lion ist das Letzte, was da draufläuft auf der Kiste. Du kannst aber, wie gesagt, du kannst halt einen VM-Ware drauflaufen lassen. Und VM-Ware kann halt einen Mavericks laufen lassen. Aber warum? Weil der seine eigenen Grafikkartentreiber hat.
Oder so eine virtuelle Grafikkarte, die ehe.
Der erfindet einfach eine 64-Bit-Grafikkarte.
Jaja, genau, sonst würde ja gar nichts laufen.
Ich hab ja meinen Mavericks auch erst mal in eine VM reingetan, weil ich so ein bisschen vorsichtig bin. Aber das ist natürlich eine gute Idee. So kann man alte Hardware nochmal ernsthaft nutzen.
Und was ich sagen wollte, da schlägt das mit dem komprimierten Speicher mal so richtig gut durch. Also es läuft ganz erträglich, muss ich sagen. Und das witzige ist, du kannst halt, wenn du das entsprechend konfiguriert hast, kannst du dich halt direkt auch per Remote, ne, das ist ja nicht Remote Desktop, wie heißt das irgendwie? Entfernte Anmeldung, wie auch immer, VNC. Screensharing kannst du dich halt direkt an die VM connecten. Und dann kannst du halt da irgendwie machen.
Das ist ja nur VNC, die VM spricht nicht diese, also um das, schuldigung, jetzt muss ich mal gerade kurz klugscheißen, da gibt die da tolle Kommentare, ich sehe das schon kommen. Das, was Apple Screensharing nennt, ist ja für die Bildübertragung vom Prinzip VNC, aber sie haben sich selber noch tausend andere Sachen drum rum gebastelt. Zum Beispiel so eine User Authentication, dass man ein Username Passwort eingeben kann, oder dass es so einen Gastzugang gibt, den man da anfragen kann, oder, oder, oder, oder, die haben sich da noch tausend Features dazu gebaut. Dieses Screensharing Programm von Apple kann aber auch mit einem normalen VNC einfach laufen. Man kann auch übrigens für die Hörer, die das gerne mal ausprobieren wollen, einfach mal ein Oll aufrufen. Kann man einfach mal in seinen Safari oben vnc-doppelpunkt-slash-slash irgendwas eingeben, so ein anderes Gerät oder so, das wird entweder VNC oder Apple Screensharing macht und sich damit verbinden. Und VMWare hat oder Virtual Box auch, ich weiß nicht ob Parallels auch, aber VMWare und Virtual Box bieten halt eben auch für die virtuellen Maschinen sowas an, dass man sich eben auf die Konsole von den Dingern drauf connecten kann. Und das ist das, was du meintest, ne?
Das ist nicht das, was ich meinte. Nein, nein, das ist nicht das, was ich meinte, sondern ich hab in der VM tatsächlich Back to my Mac angeschaltet. Und konnte dann über Back to my Mac normales Screensharing machen.
Gut, dann ist aber Apple. Ich dachte du meinst jetzt, das von außen auf die VM drauf. Du kannst nämlich, wie gesagt, dem VMWare sagen, dann kannst du dem Ding sogar beim Booten zugucken. Den siehst du ja sonst nicht über Screensharing. Das hab ich nämlich gemacht, als ich mein virtuellen Mavericks installiert habe. Da willst du ja zugucken, da willst du jetzt nicht irgendwie eine halbe Stunde einen schwarzen Screensharing Bildschirm haben. Und da kannst du eben in die VM raufgucken, wie auf die Konsole, auf die echte Glotze sozusagen.
Also, um es kurz zu sagen, Compressed Memory works. Und ein Wunder ist passiert, Mavericks macht auf einmal Hardware wieder erschließbar, die man mit Mountain Lion schon fast aufgeben wollte. Und es ist auch erstaunlich, was alles unterstützt wird. Also, eine Freundin von mir hat irgendwie noch einen 17 Zoll MacBook Pro von 2007. Das ist das älteste Gerät, glaube ich, was unterstützt wird. Das ist das älteste MacBook Pro. Und naja, da du auch irgendwie 6 GB reinstecken kannst, eine SSD, kannst du da wahrscheinlich noch ein richtig kleines Flammenschwert irgendwie draus bauen. So, jetzt kommen wir aber zu dem geilsten Tool, wo ich wirklich begeistert bin. Also über diesen Fullscreen habe ich ja wirklich viel gerannt in den letzten zwei Jahren. Aber ich glaube, abgesehen von so ein paar kleineren Glitches, die noch drin sind, diesmal haben sie echt ins Schwarze getroffen. Also diese ganze Diskussion über Screens und Multiple Desktops und hin und her Schalten und wie geht man mit verschiedenen Bildschirmen um und die ganze Debatte, die seit Jahren spielt.
Die haben halt zwei Jahre gebraucht, um das Optimum zu finden. Ist aber okay, wenn sich die Zeit nehmen.
Ja, genau, ist völlig in Ordnung, wenn es nicht zu lange dauert.
So, das sind ja noch keine Windows-Verhältnisse.
Also wenn es am Ende passt, dann passt es. Und ich muss sagen, ich habe mich schwer getan mit diesem Mission-Control, ich habe mich schwer getan mit dem Screens. Und jetzt erst habe ich begriffen, dass es alles daran lag, dass sie diesen letzten Schritt quasi noch machen mussten, den sie jetzt gegangen sind. Dass sie einfach mal die Bildschirme besser voneinander koppeln. Ich meine, dieser ganze Multiple Screen Handling-Kram, der geht ja noch zurück auf den Macintosh 2. Das ist eine Technologie, die ist in Mac OS seit 1900.
Wir sind jetzt mitten im Syracusa-Review.
Ja, wann war das?
War das da auch drin?
1994?
Aber er hat einen Screenshot. Was ich lustig fand, war, ich hatte das Ding auf dem iPad gelesen. Und der Screenshot war halt irgendwie so groß, dass er irgendwie gerade komplett aufs iPad gepasst hat.
Der Screenshot, wo von?
Von dem Apple II. Nein, da war so ein Screenshot von dem Apple II System 6. System 6 drauf mit dem Kontrollfeld, wo man die Monitore anordnen konnte.
Du willst nur nicht sagen, dass der Mac II einen größeren Screen hat als dein iPad?
Nee, genau die richtige Größe. Genau die Größe und ich dachte mir, wo ist jetzt eigentlich die Mac II Emulation fürs iPad? Das war doch jetzt genau das Richtige.
Ja, na gut, auf jeden Fall dieses, was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Also diese Idee, diese Bildschirme einfach nur irgendwie zusammen zu flanschen, die hat sich ja einfach lange gehalten. Und ich weiß nicht, ob sie die nicht aufgeben wollten oder ob sie nur nicht genau wissen, wie.
Manchmal müssen Menschen sterben, damit Ideen sterben.
Da ist was dran. So und jetzt haben sie irgendwie eine Melange aus zwei Ansätzen gemacht. Sie trennen es nicht komplett, sie lassen es noch verbunden, aber es ist jetzt zumindest klar, wo ein Fenster ist. Das ist schon mal wirklich eine Menge wert. Also es ist einfach immer klar, wo ein Fenster gerade zu Hause ist. Es ist entweder da oder es ist da und es lappt nicht mehr rüber. Was super ist. Es kann dann immer noch rechts rauslappen, aber es lappt nicht auf irgendeinen anderen Bildschirm. Und das hier gerade für das Setup hier in der Mitter-Ebene ist das einfach brillant.
Haben sie aber auch schon Leute beschwert, deswegen gibt es so einen Hidden Default, da kann man sie wieder einschalten.
Ja, da hast du den ganzen alten Modus, aber da hast du den Vorteil nicht von dem neuen. Aber jetzt macht auch dieses Mission-Control Sinn, weil jetzt kannst du einfach, jetzt habe ich auch sofort angefangen, diese ganzen Gesten, die ich immer gehasst habe, habe ich jetzt alle wieder eingeschaltet, überall auf einem System, weil ich jetzt nicht mehr genug davon kriegen kann. Wenn man jetzt nämlich irgendwie Mission-Control anmacht, hast du das ja auf allen Bildschirmen. Und du hast auf jedem Bildschirm n Screens. Und die Screens sind dem Bildschirm zugeordnet. Also Bildschirm meine ich jetzt sozusagen ein, wie soll man denn das jetzt trennen, also die Begriffe, also Screen, Bildschirm, wenn ich jetzt Bildschirm sage, meine ich halt...
Also ihr müsst euch jetzt vorstellen, Tim hat gerade diese Geste gemacht, und jetzt sind da zwei Bildschirme, 27 Zoll auf dem Schreibtisch und einmal das Bild auf dem Beamer, und alle zeigen einen Mission Control und alle zeigen unterschiedlich viele Desktops und unterschiedlich viele Programme und Fenster und Zeug, und das sieht großartig aus.
Das sieht großartig aus, und vor allem kann ich jetzt hier an beliebigen, also wenn ich jetzt sage Bildschirme, meine ich quasi so ein... Pixel-Rechteck auf ein sichtbares Ding, und Screens sind ja diese Dinger, die man dann da aufmachen kann.
Diese als Desktop 123 bezeichnen.
Ja genau, du kannst halt beliebige Desktops aufmachen, beziehungsweise du kriegst so einen ja auch automatisch, wenn du ein Programm in Fullscreen machst.
Genau. Aber dann heißt es nicht mehr Desktop, sondern heißt es so wie das Programm, das gerade in Fullscreen ist.
Genau, also das ist aber auch ganz sinnvoll, dass so ein Fullscreen-Programm quasi ist wie ein eigener Desktop, weil es nimmt ihn ja komplett ein. Aber er gehört halt trotzdem immer noch zu diesem physikalischen Bildschirm dazu. Und jetzt kannst du trotzdem halt ein Programm nehmen und das einfach mal auf einen ganz anderen Bildschirm legen und da auf einem beliebigen Screen. Und immer noch ist dieser Mission Control an. Also der Überblick, den man hier auf einmal gewinnt, der ist einfach enorm. Und ich hab das jetzt viel getestet, auch gerade über dieses Wochenende, weil es kommt ja noch ein zweites Feature hinzu. Die Möglichkeit, jetzt einen Airplay-Bildschirm als zweiten Bildschirm zu machen, so als wäre er wirklich über HDMI angeschlossen. Er ermöglicht dir auch noch mal denselben Spagat damit. Und da hab ich mich natürlich, und du kennst ja immer dieses Problem, was war vorher, wenn man dann einen Bildschirm abgestöpselt hat? Dann kollabieren alle Fenster auf dem einen. Und wenn du den dann irgendwann wieder anschließt, dann kannst du von Glück sagen, wenn du irgendwie halbwegs dein altes Setup wieder so hinkriegst.
Ja, aber das wär immer noch so.
Nee, weil jetzt gehen halt diese einzelnen virtuellen Screens sortieren sich jetzt einfach in die anderen mit rein und wenn du die anderen wieder aktivierst, den zweiten Bildschirm, dann hüpfen die auch gleich wieder rüber. Also diese virtuellen Screens bleiben quasi im Ursprungsbildschirm enthalten.
Die Windows kommt nicht zurück, sondern der ganze Screen mit seiner Konfiguration der Windows kommt komplett zurück.
Also sagen wir mal so, ich mach jetzt Airplay als zweiten Bildschirm. Und da mach ich zwei Screens auf. Einmal den normalen Desktop und dann hab ich ein Programm Fullscreen, so die beiden. Jetzt schalt ich Airplay aus, schwupps, hab ich drei Screens auf meinem eingebauten Bildschirm. Mach ich Airplay wieder an, schwupps, marschieren die beiden Screens wieder auf den anderen. Das muss man echt ausprobiert haben, um's genießen zu können, aber es ist eine Freude.
Vielleicht traf ich doch noch mal eine Apple TV.
Es macht wirklich, es macht super Spaß und so eine Apple TV ist auch auf solchen Veranstaltungen super, weil jederzeit jeder auf Zuruf mal eben den Bildschirm übernehmen kann.
Jetzt aber immer noch limitiert nur auf die neueren Macs, die ohnehin Bildschirme nach Apple TV kopieren können.
Richtig, genau, also nur die können das. Also ich weiß nicht, von wann fing das so an? 2010? Ich weiß nicht genau. Also alles, was so ein bisschen neuer ist, kann das.
Nee, ich hab 2010 und meiner kann das nicht.
Ich hab Anfang 2011 und der kann das.
Genau, 2011 fing es an, genau. Mit 2011 fing es an. Ja, ja, ich hab das hier auch auf meinem Mac Pro nicht. Aber egal, unabhängig von dem Airplay, in diesem Genuss des neuen Bildschirmhandlings kommst du auch so, das ist richtig geil. Also ich liebe das. Ich kann den ganzen Tag dieses Mission Control auf und zu machen.
Da war sie endlich wieder, die Tim-Begeisterung, die uns so gefehlt hat. Die uns so gefehlt hat.
Das ist toll.
Wir sehen die Zukunft wieder.
Er leckt jetzt an seinen Bildschirmen, an der Mission Control.
Okay, was ist das nächste große Feature?
Eine Frage noch mal kurz dazu. Wenn du sagst, du hast jetzt die Gesten an, das heißt, du hast jetzt diese Ecken auch an, oder was?
Die Hotspots meinst du?
Da ist jetzt nicht die spannende Frage. In deinem Setup mit deinen drei Monitoren, wenn du da Hot-Ecken anmachst, sind die in den einzelnen Bildschirmen oder muss ich immer mit der Maus nach ganz, ganz, ganz rechts fahren? In den rechtesten Bildschirm, dann die obere Ecke, wenn ich dann sozusagen die rechte obere Ecke haben will?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Also ich verwende immer Hot-Corners, aber ich kann es dir auch nicht sagen.
Hot-Corners.
Also das wäre nämlich mal interessant, ob jetzt die Corners auch in jedem Bildschirm einzeln sind oder ob die sozusagen wieder für das ganze Ding gelten.
Wo muss man denn das überhaupt einschalten?
Mission Control und dann unten links aktive Ecken.
Mission Control.
Also was ich zum Beispiel sehr häufig brauche, ist diese Hot-Corner, die mir mal den Desktop kurz wusst, die zeigt, wie man meine Fenster gerade mal zur Seite räumt.
Ich hab da immer Bildschirmschoner an und Bildschirmschoner aus.
Also ich könnte jetzt mal Mission Control mit...
Da unten, der Button. Links unten, Hot-Corner.
Ja, siehst du mal, ich kenn das so wenig.
So, dann machst du mal rechts oben.
Links unten, Mission Controls. Fahr ich hier nach links unten, dann kommt Mission Controls. Gehe ich auf den anderen Bildschirm. Und da geht's auch.
Aha, das heißt, die Ecken sind jetzt pro Bildschirm.
Ja, aber ist sehr schön gerecht.
Und dann kommt man immer aus Versehen ran und dann passieren da tausend Landlöcher.
Das waren sie auch schon.
Ja, da muss man die Bildschirme so arrangieren, dass man auch ordentliche Corners hat, wenn man davon was haben will. Aber das finde ich jetzt irgendwie nicht so, weiß ich nicht, Hot Corners.
Ja, benutze ich, wie gesagt, deswegen frage ich.
Ja, Gesten, also so vier Finger hoch und vier Finger runter, das macht auf einmal total Sinn.
Das kann ich aber nicht benutzen, weil einer meiner Hauptanwendungsfälle ist für Dreck und Drop. Ich habe ein Fenster vorne und noch 20 andere dazwischen und möchte jetzt aus dem vorderen Fenster irgendetwas draggen in ein anderes Fenster rein, da hinten. Und deswegen habe ich bei mir einen Hot Corn, weil ich dann nicht mit dem gedrackten Objekt in der Hand sozusagen, in der Maus, kurz in die Ecke fahre, dann klappen die alle auf, dann fahre ich mit der Maus auf das Fenster, wo ich hin soll, lasse sie dort stehen, dann macht es so blink blink und dann kommt dieses Fenster nach vorne. Ja, aber dafür hat uns auch der Hagolt ein Funktionstasten gegeben. Ja, ich kann jetzt aber nicht nochmal... Funktionskasten war Windows, ich hab keine Funktionskasten bei mir. Und ich kann jetzt nicht mit wat in der Hand, wat ich gerade drecken und droppen will, jetzt plötzlich mit vier Fingern noch auf meinem Touchpad rumeiern.
Warum seid ihr auf vier? Bei mir sind es nur drei.
Doch, das geht, das ist aber ein bisschen schwierig. Besonders die zeigen mir den Bildschirm, also den Desktop-Hintergrund an, um was dort abzulegen, die ist besonders schwierig, die Geste beim Draggen.
Oh ja, dieses Auseinanderfalten, ne?
Ja, man hat den Daumen, um das Trackpad runterzudrücken und versucht dann mit den anderen Fingern so ein Spagat hinzulegen.
Ich glaube, da muss man erstmal zum Yoga-Kurs, bevor man das irgendwie richtig hinkriegt.
Nee, das geht, also zumindest mit diesem Extra Magic Trackpad geht das relativ gut. Mit dem eingebauten ist es ein bisschen schwieriger.
Extra Magic?
Das Zusatz externe.
Das Bluetooth-Trackpad.
Das Tragic Macpad. Ja, also gut, ich hab nichts gegen Funktionshasten. Ich find Funktionshasten an sich ganz sinnvoll. Und weil Dennis gerade gefragt hat, der Default für diese Mission-Control-Geste ist natürlich drei Finger, aber ich stelle häufig fest, dass wenn ich so einen Zwei-Finger-Scroll mache, schon häufiger mal noch ein dritter Finger mitschleift. Und deswegen trenne ich das lieber voneinander.
Ich hab das auch getrennt, aber aus einem anderen Grund. Und zwar gibt es irgendwie unter Weitere mit Streichenblättern. Wenn man das anhat, da steht...
Mit Streichenblättern?
Mit Streichenblättern heißt das.
In Werbung verschieben.
Mit Streichen in Werbung verschieben.
Oh, mit Streichenblättern.
Mit Streichenblättern. Ja, das ist...
Steht auf diesen modernen iOS-Geräten, die er da verwendet, eigentlich immer noch dieses zum Entsperren streichen. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, man müsste gleich mit so Alpina-Wise irgendwie daherkommen.
Zum Entsperren streichen geht nicht weg. Naja, wie auch immer. Das ist im Standard auf Zwei-Finger gesetzt. Und das hat aber zur Folge, dass wenn man in, ich glaube, das war in Safari sehr lange, mit Zwei-Fingern horizontal scrollt, dass es einem passieren kann, dass man, dass der Scroll-Inhalt irgendwie ans Ende kommt und bounce und man dann aber zurückblättert.
Das ist völlig chaotisch.
Genau, und deswegen habe ich mit streichen blättern auf drei Finger gesetzt und dann muss man aber die anderen Gesten auf vier Finger setzen.
Apple-Finger-Yoga.
Da gibt es auch diese alten Videos, weißt du noch?
Old Shatterhand?
Nein, diese Mouse-Training-Videos. Point and click. Wie heißen die denn?
Leading emails.
Das waren diese Demovideos für diese ersten Quicktime-Funktionen. Also mal Mouse... Wie war denn das? Verdammt. Oh man, Chat-Hilfe.
Chat-Hilf?
Ja, ich hab das Video sogar auf dem Rechner. Ich weiß es, aber ich weiß gerade nicht, wonach ich suchen soll. Dieser Typ, der irgendwie erklärt, wie man so mit der Mouse ein bisschen shake that carpal tunnel.
Mars-Attacks. Darf ich mal kurz ein bisschen maulen über Mavericks? Nur so Kleinigkeiten. Apple hat uns ja schon vor ewigem Zeiten verboten, X11 zu benutzen. Erst haben sie es nur runtergeschmissen mit den neuen Versionen und man konnte das von Apple nachladen. Jetzt muss man ja nicht seit Lion oder Mountain Lion muss man sich das ja separat installieren mit Xquads. Aber wenn man das jetzt schon sich von separat holt, dann würde ich doch sagen, das ist doch eine Applikation. Nichtsdestotrotz hat Mavericks erstmal wieder meine X11-Installation. Das ist einfach nur diese offizielle Xquads, was Apple ja auch selber empfiehlt in diesem Fall, erstmal wieder kaputt gemacht. Und das finde ich irgendwie komisch. Das finde ich irgendwie scheiße.
Du weißt, wenn du das Update des Mavericks, dann geht es Xquads nicht mehr.
Richtig. Also ich habe jetzt auf dem bestehenden Mountain Lion einen Mavericks drauf gemacht, in meiner VM. Und ich benutze X11 hauptsächlich für ein Spielzeug, nämlich für Wireshark. Und trotzdem machte das irgendwie kaputt in welche Libraries oder sonst wo möglich.
Du weißt, dass Wireshark gerade auf GTK gewechselt ist? Nee, von GTK auf OT gewechselt ist?
Die wollen. Das dauert noch ein bisschen wat.
Sicher?
Also, ich habe die Ankündigung gelesen, dass sie das machen. Aber bis es so weit ist, dass es rum ist und es sozusagen einen NatiWit Wireshark gibt für einen Mac, das dauert noch ein bisschen, glaube ich. Also, die haben eine Alpha gebaut davon. Da funktionieren aber von, was weiß ich, in der GUI von 100 Buttons funktionieren 5 oder so. Das ist so ein Ding, um zu zeigen, dass man es grundsätzlich machen kann. Und jetzt portieren sie da weiter dran und stellen das alles um und machen und tun. Aber bis ich wieder das Wireshark habe, was ich jetzt unter X11 habe, das dauert noch ein paar Monate. Egal. Aber wie gesagt, das macht Apple, obwohl es jetzt gar nicht mehr zum Lieferempfang gehört oder wie auch immer, machen sie trotzdem erst mal kaputt. War einfach zu reparieren, lädst du einfach das X-Cores wieder runter, installierst es und musst ja nur sagen, ja, haben wir, accept, accept, da, da, da, geht es wieder alles ganz toll. Aber trotzdem finde ich es ein bisschen...
Naja, aber du musst zugeben, dass X11 natürlich irgendwie so ein komplexer Scheiß ist und dass der kaputt geht. Das kann man jetzt eigentlich auch denken.
Nee, es ist aber komplex. Es ist eine Applikation wie jede andere auch an dieser Stelle. Also, und ich erwarte ja auch nicht, dass Mavericks mir irgendwie eine andere Applikation, die ich mir irgendwo gekauft habe, kaputt macht. Dass die Applikation dann selber, sagen wir mal, nicht mehr geht, weil sie irgendwelche betriebssystemspezifischen Sachen macht. Das ist was anderes. Aber ich installiere ja genau dasselbe X11 nach. Das ist übrigens eine Version, glaube ich, die nur für Lion gibt oder so. Das ist egal. Also der letzte Xquartz, das ist gar nicht für Mavericks extra gemacht worden. Das reinstallierst du einfach wieder und geht. Das heißt also irgendwie machen sie es dir kaputt. Er war jetzt unter einem kleiner Rind. Aber trotzdem, genau wie mit dieser Jabberkacke. Ich mag auch keinen Jabber, aber es gibt halt eben manche Applikationen, die brauchen das. Warum muss das jetzt immer so unglaublich painful sein? Steve ist doch tot. Kann man jetzt nicht einfach mal locker damit umgehen? Kann man nicht mal so eine Systempräferenz haben, wo ich mal anklicken kann, ein für alle Mal? Ja, ich weiß, Jabber ist scheiße. Ja, ich weiß, Flash ist scheiße. Aber ich brauche das manchmal doch. Kannst du das bitte laden, ohne mich jedes Mal voll zu kotzen und mich zu ärgern? Nach jedem System update, alles wieder runterzuschmeißen und so. Ich fühle mich da so ein bisschen überbevormundet.
Nee, was ich zu X11 nur sagen wollte, der rotzt halt ganz schön in irgendwelchen Unix-Verzeichnissen rum. Und es kann halt sein, dass Apple die einfach mal leer macht und da tabula rasa macht. Und dass du das Zeug halt neu installieren musst. Ist ja nicht so, als wäre jetzt wirklich diese gesamte X11-Installation in der X11-App irgendwie gekapselt. Schön wär's. Aber ich glaube, das werden wir nicht mehr erleben in diesem Jahrtausend.
Vielleicht machen die Xquads Leute das noch mal. Aber weiß man nicht, keine Ahnung.
Fünf Sterne von mir, sofort.
Eine andere Sache, die mir aufgefallen ist, ist jetzt kein Mangel an Apple. Aber ich habe noch für bestimmte Sachen, ich gebe jetzt offiziell zu, unter Zeugen, ich habe noch ein Windows XP aus von Anno Tuff in einer virtuellen, also in so einer Parallels VM. Weil ich noch Hardware betreuen muss, die nur über irgendwelche Maintenance-Software unter Windows zu bedienen ist.
Das kenn ich.
Kennt ihr bestimmt. Es gibt so irgendwelche Geräte, die man per USB-Kabel an eine Windows-Maschine anklinken muss, um sie zu konfigurieren und dann mit neuer Software zu beflaschen, oder wie auch immer. Hab ich auch, fliegt. Ich hab noch ein paar da rum. Alles ganz toll. Deswegen hab ich extra Windows XP, weil diese Software ist so alt und so scheiße, dass ich gar nicht ausprobieren wollte, ob die überhaupt noch unter Windows 7 oder so läuft. Aber schön mit Windows XP in der Parallels-Installation. Alles toll. Jetzt guckt man natürlich, bevor man so einen Upgrade macht und stellt fest, Parallels spielt in letzter Zeit immer das mit. Wenn es eine neue Betriebssystemversion gibt von Apple, musst du auch immer eine neue Major-Version von Parallels kaufen. Das heißt, inzwischen ist die Situation so, dass das Betriebssystem, was ich hauptsächlich nutze, nämlich OS X, ist inzwischen umsonst. Vielen Dank, Apple, finde ich einen echt geilen Move, kann man auch noch mal laut sagen. Dass sie jetzt so ein Major-Betriebssystem, ein Software-Update für Ume, raus tun, finde ich sehr sexy. Und die Maschinerie, die ich brauche, um ein Betriebssystem, was ich hasse und was ich überhaupt nie eigentlich gerne benutzen will, weiter betreiben zu können, die wollen von mir richtig Patte haben.
Wo du seit zwölf Jahren kein Geld für bezahlt hast, nehme ich mal an.
Was für Parallels? Nö, das ist eine richtig echte Lizenz, die habe ich damals echt mal gekauft. Aber dafür, aber das Geld drücke ich jetzt nicht weder an Microsoft noch an Apple ab, sondern das schiebe ich jetzt Parallels in den Rachen. Beziehungsweise ich werde jetzt damit genau aufhören, weil ich benutze sonst in meinen Servern und so was benutze ich vor allem Wer oder Virtual Box und werde jetzt hingehen und werde jetzt mal Parallels mal den Finger zeigen und sagen Nö, die keine Ahnung 49, 45 Euro für den Upgrade diesmal, die könnt ihr euch mal schieben. Weil sie machen kaum noch was dran. Du siehst immer nur, ah ja, die 3D-Performance für Spiele ist jetzt besser. Und ich so, ja klar, ich spiele auch sehr viel unter Windows auf dem Mac. Aber ansonsten ändert sich an dieser Geschichte nichts mehr. Trotzdem schieben sie immer wieder neue Versionen raus, die total kostenpflichtig sind. Und sie zwingen dich, mit jeder Apple-Betriebssystem-Version eine neue Parallelsversion zu kaufen. Und das steht jetzt einfach nicht mehr im Verhältnis zu den anderen Sachen. Und deswegen kann man, sag jetzt mal, Parallels... Tschüss!...
Das war's.
Naja, ich meine, die waren die ersten auf dem Mac, aber sie sind halt einfach nicht die besten.
Rennpause....
für so ein bisschen Übung hier, ne? Moment.
Lass uns ein bisschen Macarobik machen.
Öffne das Fenster, klopft das Fenster!
Kommand-X, Kommand-Y, mach es burnen, Kommand-X und Kommand-Option-X. Das ist es, Kommand-Option-Y.
Das ist wirklich super und es gibt da ein bisschen Geschichte. Ich hab sie jetzt leider nicht mehr so ganz parat. Der Typ hat glaube ich noch ein zweites Video gemacht, aber das war so super populär und das war so aus dieser Zeit, als das mit QuickTime überhaupt das richtig losging. Siehst ja schon, die Auflösung hier, Audioqualität und so weiter. Ist alles nicht. Das ist halt uralt und war genau so lustig gemeint, wie es immer noch rüberkommt.
Hier, wo wir gerade bei Mavericks Free waren. Das heißt ja immer, if you're not paying, you're the product. Und naja, muss man ja auch mal überlegen.
Oder wie die Deutschen sagen, was nichts kostet, ist nichts.
Ja, aber es kommt ja mit einem Dongle. Und für den Dongle musst du ja auch ein bisschen Geld bezahlen.
Was ich meine, ist, was sie auch an Features wieder wegstreichen. Was sie an Features wieder wegstreichen. Und zwar kann ich jetzt nicht mehr mein fucking Adressbuch mit meinem iPhone sinken, außer ich benutze deren Cloud. Okay, Adressbuch ist jetzt erstmal nicht so groß, aber auf lange Sicht wollen die natürlich, dass ich die Gigabyte nachkaufe. Womit ich auch nicht mal ein Problem hätte. Aber ich nutze halt die Cloud nicht, weil ich keinen Bock auf mein Adressbuch auf fremden Rechnern habe. Und das finde ich ein bisschen scheiße. Also wo ist denn der Vorteil, wenn ich mein Adressbuch erst bei denen auf die Cloud schiebe und erst dann auf meinen Rechner kriege? Also warum können sie da nicht beides anlassen?
Kannst du noch mal sagen, was genau nicht funktioniert?
Also pass auf, ich habe hier mein Adressbuch auf meinem Rechner und ich kaufe mir ein neues Telefon, einfach mal schließe es an und dann kann ich an iTunes sagen, schiebe mal mein Adressbuch auf mein Telefon. Und das geht jetzt nicht mehr, außer du benutzt halt iCloud, über iCloud geht das noch. Dann kannst du dein Adressbuch auf allen Rechnern aufgesunken und so, aber mit Mavericks kannst du es nicht mehr direkt machen.
Stopp, falsch. Du kannst es nicht mehr über das Kabel oder Wifi machen. Du musst aber nicht iCloud benutzen. Ich benutze zum Beispiel nicht iCloud, ich benutze meinen eigenen CardDAV-Server und meinen eigenen CalDAV-Server und das geht hervorragend. Ja, du musst es über das Netz, du kannst es auch über den USX-Server selber hintun oder von anderen Anbietern. Ich will nur sagen, das ist nicht an iCloud gebunden.
Habe ich auch gelesen, aber trotzdem ist es nicht schön. Sie haben dann Feature entfernt, haben dann nichts von gesagt und vor allem ist das Feature schon, das war schon da und sie machen es aus.
Ja, du hast mit dem Teil recht, dass sie was altes weggenommen haben, aber ich wollte nur sagen, du bist nicht gezwungen, Apple iCloud zu benutzen. Du musst halt irgendeinen Server benutzen, aber du musst nicht Apple iCloud benutzen.
Gmail haben sie auch rausgeschmissen. Gmail haben sie auch rausgeschmissen.
Hat das hier funktioniert?
Ein bisschen.
Ich mach Gmail mit IMAP.
Was noch eine Verschlimmbesserung ist bei Mavericks, ich guck letztens hier so eine Serie, wie ich immer so Serien gucke. Ja, ich mach meinen Mac Pro an, weil da sind die alle drauf. Im Laptop geh ich ins Bett, mounte das Ding, guck mir den Film an, klicke und gucke und auf einmal so mittendrin aus. Ich so, hä? Guck ich? Ist der Mac Pro einfach in seinen Sleep Mode gegangen? Die benutzen jetzt ja SMB2 für Mavericks zu Mavericks mounten. Und dem ist egal, ob du das gerade gemountet hast oder nicht. Wenn deine Schlafzeit rum ist, dann geht der Rechner schlafen, obwohl du da noch eingeloggt oder angemeldet bist. Das war vorher nicht der Fall. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt die Sleep-Date von meinem Mac Pro auf mal so zwei Stunden stellen, damit er mal so einen Film durchhält, weil... Sonst schläft er mittendrin ein.
Wie fährst du ihn einfach, wenn er als Server arbeitet?
Wie als Server? Rund um die Uhr?
Er braucht seinen ganzen Strom für die Bitcoin-Miner.
So sieht's aus.
Warum sollen Rechner anbleiben, den man sonst nicht braucht? Früher war es so, ich hab den Mac Pro angemacht, hab das gemacht und hab den Film geguckt und wenn ich dann meinen Laptop einfach zugeklappt habe, dann hat er das ja automatisch abgemeldet wegen Timeout und dann ist der Rechner, der Mac Pro, der hat auch nicht dann die halbe Stunde gewartet, sondern der hat gemerkt, der Sack ist eingeschlafen, sonst hat mich ja auch schon seit einer Stunde keiner benutzt, dann ist der sofort schlaf gegangen, also nach einer Minute oder so. Und das war schon ziemlich perfekt.
Ja, das lag an AFP, weil AFP das Schlafen verändert hat.
Genau, was ich auch gut finde.
Das müssen Sie jetzt mit SMB 2 auch noch dazu bringen.
Dann sollen Sie doch den Mac Pro anlassen, wenn das SMB irgendwie gemountet ist. Aber sollen halt auf der anderen Seite, also auf dem Laptop, mit dem ich mounte, da mich dein Auto abmelden, wenn ich irgendwie schon seit einer halben Stunde das File-System nicht mehr benutzt habe. Und dann könnte ja die andere Seite automatisch auch runterfahren. Aber dass Sie einfach trotzdem runterfahren, ob du da sogar aktiv gerade Daten rüber schickst, das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Das ist in meinen Augen ein Bug. Ist ja nicht so ein Riesending. Können wir fixen oder vielleicht wollen wir es ja auch nicht. So ist ja eine Policy-Sache. Aber das hat mich ein bisschen, finde ich, fand ich doof. Und ob die da SMP2 nehmen oder AFP, wenn es schneller, besser, weiter, sonst wie es kriegst du eh nicht mit, was sie da unten drunter benutzen. Benutzt ja schon seit Jahren IPv6-Lokal, stimmt Clemens. Und das hat ja auch keiner mitbekommen. Also hauptsächlich funktioniert. Aber das geht nicht. Ich gucke filmen und mittendrin, verstehst du? Das ist gerade die Szene.
Dann setz einfach deinen Scheiß-Sleep-Timer auf zwei Stunden.
Ja, hab ich ja. Aber es ist auch kacke. Es kostet wieder mehr Strom. Oder man muss nochmal aufstehen und muss sein Rechner ausmachen. Das ist auch kacke.
Da war einfach Strom ran.
Kannst du dich remote ausmachen?
Ich wollte ja gerade sagen, kannst du ja remote runterfahren, das Ding.
Ja, könnte man vielleicht.
Wenn der Film scheiße ist und du einschliffst bei dem Film, dann willst du, dass dann automatisch alle drunter klappen.
Wenn ich müde bin, dann einfach nur noch Deckel zu und los schnallen.
Dann geht doch sowieso irgendwann aus, wenn der Akku alles.
Nee, ich hab auch Schlafzimmer Strom für mein Laptop. Aber da sind wir bei der nächsten coolen Sache, bei Mavericks. Und zwar dieses ganze Energiezeugs bei Mavericks. Das ist schon ziemlich cool. Vielleicht ist es nur so psychologisch, aber ich hab auch das Gefühl, dass mein MacBook Pro, dass die Batterie nicht so schnell leer wird wie vorher. Das ist unfassbar.
Ich hab den ganzen Tag das Teil im Betrieb gehabt und es wollte gar nicht leer werden.
Ja gut, man kann auch eben mal gucken, wenn der Lüfter hochdreht, wer ist denn das? Schießt den ab und dann geht's weiter.
Ja, aber auch so, wenn er keinen abschießt, ich glaube, es hält schon so ein bisschen besser. Und ich hab auch bei mir ein Ding entdeckt, der irgendwie anscheinend Strom zieht. Und zwar dieses SMC Fan-Control, was ich ihm anhatte, wo man oben die Lüfter sehen kann. Der war bei mir immer als Top-Verbraucher. Der machte immer nichts. Und alle zwei Sekunden machte er dann voll viel. Er ist immer an, aus, an, aus, ganz komisch. Und vielleicht ist er nicht so der wirklich hohe Verbraucher, weil er das immer nur manchmal macht. Aber irgendwie sah es in deren Energie-Einstellung da so aus. Der war da auf jeden Fall immer auf dem ersten Platz. Und jetzt seitdem mach ich den immer aus.
Du musst da mal die richtigen Timer einbauen. Die Coalescing Timer. Dann wird alles gut.
Der Typ bei SMC Fan-Control meinste?
Ja, also ich glaube, Mavericks, man kann zusammenfassen.
Ist gut.
Ist gut, ist gut, ist billig, ist kostenlos, ist schnell, spart an allen Ecken und Enden und schaltet nicht zu viele Features aus und schaltet einige interessante an und kriegt vor allem ein paar Sachen endlich mal gerade gebogen, die schon jahrelang im Arsch waren.
Ja, es ist auch so gefühlt so no new features release.
Na, aber im Fein haben sie schon eine ganze Menge gedreht und ich hab da mal auch diesen einen Backe, den ich in der letzten Sendung schon beschreiben wollte, was mir nicht gelungen ist.
Das sind alles so Kleinigkeiten, die keine riesigen hier, naja gut, sie machen immer ihre 200 Feature-Dinger, aber ich meine, das ist jetzt nichts, wo man sagt, das ist jetzt ein groundbreaking new Feature, sondern das sind viele Kleinigkeiten, die sich zu so einem stabileren System zusammen addieren und nicht irgendwie...
Altwie können sie so weitermachen. Also sie können jetzt gerne noch zwei Jahre noch solche Releases machen, irgendwie, das...
Was ich noch nicht verstehe ist, warum das AirDrop vom iPhone, und sie nennt es wirklich AirDrop, nicht kompatibel ist mit dem AirDrop auf Mavericks oder auch jedem OS vorher. Nee, ist aber nicht. Kannst AirDrop auf deinem Finder anmachen, kannst AirDrop in deinem iOS 7 anmachen.
iOS 7 hat doch keiner.
Und wie kommt denn da nichts? Und das ist schon ein bisschen blöd.
Kann ich mal noch einen Hinweis zur Technik geben? Diese Wii, die du mir da gegeben hast, die ist falsch programmiert.
Auf was denn?
Wenn ich den Button drücke, geht irgendwie das Voice Signal an, und wenn ich ihn loslasse, geht es wieder aus. Das müsste genau andersrum sein.
Das ist keine Rolls-Royce-Taste, das ist eine Push-to-Talk-Taste.
Dann werd ich das mal fixen. Gibst du mir das Teil mal bitte?
Liebe Zuhörer, tut uns ja leid, dass wir jetzt immer noch wieder an dem Setup basteln müssen. Das liegt aber daran, dass das einfach nicht stabil zu kriegen ist.
Wollt ihr tatsächlich jetzt noch groß über den MacBook Pro reden?
Über die neuen Geräte oder was?
Nö, nur falls irgendjemand da was aufgefallen ist. Es gibt neue MacBook Pros.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, mein Kollege hat eins bestellt, das kam gestern an und er hat es heute nicht mitgebracht in die Arbeit, deswegen kann ich nichts dazu sagen und ich bin da auch böse drüber.
Mit Mavericks hat Apple ja eingeführt, dass man auch über Thunderbolt ein bisschen Netzwerken kann. Ja stimmt, es gibt Ethernet über Thunderbolt, ne? Das ist nämlich der Witz dabei. Apple hat ja früher Firewire, IP über Firewire gemacht.
Ja, schon sehr lange.
iSCSI ist da auch Ethernet über iSCSI oder IP über iSCSI?
Ne, andersrum. iSCSI über IP.
Und du kannst halt, das ist übrigens sehr interessant, nur so nebenbei. Irgendwann gab es ja auch mal so Windows-Maschinen, die mal Firewire hatten. Nicht viele, aber es gab ja sowas. Man konnte das nachrüsten als Karte. Und Windows hat auch Netzwerking darüber implementiert. Die haben aber damals Ethernet über Firewire gemacht. Und da kannst du auf dem Ethernet natürlich wieder IP drauf machen. Und Apple hat halt IP auf Firewire gemacht. Und jetzt machen sie das wieder bei den Thunderbolt-Anschlüssen. Da machen sie aber, wie gesagt, Ethernet über Firewire. Und da kann man natürlich jetzt wieder IP drauf machen. Lange Rede, gar kein Sinn. Man kann jetzt so zwei Macs mit Thunderbolt aneinander stöpseln.
Und hat 10 Gigabit.
Und hat dann technisch gesehen 10 Gigabit, bzw. vermutlich, wenn man jetzt zwei von den neuen Gurken ansteckt, die mit dem Thunderbolt 2 sind, vielleicht sogar 20G. Nee, 20 haben sie, glaube ich, die benutzen jetzt beide Kanäle, oder? 20G, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie jetzt nur beide Kanäle zusammen benutzen können oder ob sie den Kanal noch in 20 Gigabit Modus verpasst haben.
Wie viel kostet doch gleich noch das Kabel, was man dafür braucht?
Nee, die hatten vorher zwei Kanäle und konntest vorher schon zwei mal zehn machen, aber nie 20 mit einer Sache. Und mit dem Thunderbolt 2 kannst du jetzt irgendwie die beiden zusammen benutzen.
Clemens, kannst du mal kurz hier deinen Screensharing irgendwie ausschalten? Du hast mich hier irgendwie aus meinem eigenen Rechner rausgelockt.
Nur, was ich sagen wollte, das Spannende ist, ja, das Kabel ist teuer, aber nochmal, wenn du dir jetzt, erstens gibt es keine 10G Interfaces, also eine richtige 10G Ethernet Interfaces für einen Laptop, sondern kannst du nur einen Pro einbauen und selbst diese Dinger sind dann ziemlich teuer, die sind viel teurer als der Thunderbolt Kabel. Aber ist immerhin mal ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Was sie jetzt damit langfristig machen wollen, weiß ich nicht, aber ich denke, das geht eher so in die Richtung mit dem neuen Mac. So wie früher. Wie viele Thunderbolt Ports hat denn der Müll eimer? Sechs. Sechs? Ja, dann kann man doch sagen, das ist so für die Film-Foodsies. Die stellen sich das dann bestimmt so vor, draußen rennst du halt drum mit deinem nagelneuen MacBook Pro, machst da deine Filmaufnahmen drauf in Full HD und schieß mich tot und so, die machst du schön auf das Ding, nimmst du von draußen mit und gehst dann damit an deinen Schneideplatz und hängst jetzt dein Laptop da nicht irgendwie an dein gammliges Gigabit-Ethernet, das ist nämlich old and busted, sondern steckst da schön das Thunderbolt-Kabel rein, um das direkt in deinen Mülleimer unten unter dem Tisch reinzustecken und juckst dann die Daten aus deinem MacBook Pro in den Mülleimer mit 10G. Das wäre eine Anwendung, die ich mir ganz gut vorstellen könnte. Ich meine, das müssen jetzt nicht mal Videos sein, das können ja auch ein paar Megapixel-Fotografen sein oder sowas.
Sind die SSDs denn so schnell, dass du da einen Unterschied merkst?
Du merkst, ja, also ist es auf jeden Fall schneller als ein G.
Also die SSDs im MacBook Pro sollten so schnell sein wie in den neuen MacBook Air und so weiter und die schaffen... Wo sind die bei einem halben Gigabyte die Sekunde? Nee, mehr oder? Nee, Gigabyte die Sekunde machen die, genau.
Ich achte mal so viel wie ein Gigabit pro Sekunde, ne? Wenn ich das richtig gerechnet hab.
Also du kannst Pima Dom mal sagen, wenn du über ein Gigabit Ethernet, das schaffst, 100 Megabyte pro Sekunde rüber zu prügeln, dann ist es okay. Ja, das ist Pima Dom. Mal ein bisschen mehr, mal ein bisschen weniger. Aber die SSDs sind viel schneller und 100 Megabyte ist ja nix mehr für einen modernen Film, der jetzt vielleicht noch in 4K kommt oder wie auch immer. Also deswegen. Und gerade mit der Kombination, wenn du jetzt der Müll einmal jetzt bloß ein oder zwei von diesen Ports gehabt hättest, hätt ich gesagt, na das macht keiner, weil da stecken die dann ihre Thunderbolt-Arrays dran oder sonst ihre Disk-Arrays. Aber wenn das Ding sechs Ports hat, dann ist natürlich die Vermutung, die liegt ja nahe, dass man sich dann auch mal so ein Kabel kurft und sich dort oben auf dem Schreibtisch legt, um da seine Laptops anzuschließen.
Ja, mal gucken. Ich meine, ich hab mir auch mal überlegt, wir sind ja im Prinzip schon beim Mac Pro angekommen, weil es so Macbook Pro gibt es nicht viel zu erzählen. Ich meine, die Dinger sind irgendwie ein bisschen billiger und das 13 Zoll ist ein bisschen kleiner.
Und haben halt den neuen Chip drin. Na ist schon interessant.
Ja klar.
Haben jetzt auch bessere Batterie-Power dadurch.
Der Haswell und die interne Grafik soll viel besser sein, aber hm.
Ja, der Mac Pro bleibt...
Wollen wir über das kurz reden, was das nicht gegeben hat? Alle haben ja gesagt, es gibt auch mal neue Minis, da bin ich ja spitz drauf. Gab es nicht.
Ja, aber die Minis kommen erfahrungsgemäß ja immer deutlich später.
Also du meinst Haswell Minis.
Die werden nicht angekündigt, ne?
Und die alten Macbook Pros gibt es nicht mehr, die nicht-Retine.
15 Zoll haben sie fallen gelassen, 13 Zoll gibt es noch. Echt? Also es gibt noch das 13 Zoll Macbook Pro, das Alte mit CD-Laufwerk.
Aber der Preisunterschied von diesem behinderten Ding, das ist jetzt falsch, aber von diesem Ding gegenüber dem nächst höheren ist irgendwie keine Ahnung, 150 Euro oder so was, das wisse ich auch nicht, wer sich jetzt sowas denn kauft.
Na die Leute, die noch hier Non-Glossy haben wollen, wie heißt das?
Nee, das sind Leute, die da meinen, sie müssen mit dem Laufwerk.
Das sind Leute, die mit Retina Displays eh nix anfangen können oder was?
Das sind Leute, die aus irgendwelchen Gründen der Meinung sind, sie brauchen noch ein CD-Laufwerk.
Ein eingebautes, weil ich meine, du kriegst das externe ja mit dazu.
Ach, der Ding hat noch ein CD-Laufwerk?
Das alte MacBook Pro, davon reden wir.
Das letzte Gerät mit CD-Laufwerk, oder haben die Mini's noch CD-Laufwerke? Oder die neuen auch nicht mehr?
Nee, die iMacs auch nicht mehr.
Stimmt, die iMacs ja auch nicht mehr.
CD ist die neue Floppy, oder?
Ich schätze das sehr, dass ich hier was dran habe.
Aha, aha, da ist er. Tim ist schuld, dass es so lange gedauert hat, bis wir die losgeworden sind.
Was für CDs guckst denn du?
Na, zuletzt habe ich Disc Warrior 4.4 geguckt, der mir mein kaputtes HFS-Fallsystem, was ja laut Aussage von Apple nicht kaputt geht, wieder heile gemacht hat. Wo waren wir gerade? Ach ja, bei dem Mac Pro, das unbekannte Wesen. Also ich habe mir dann alles herausgelegt.
Also warte, erstmal muss man sagen, ich habe Recht gehabt.
Mit Preis?
Ne, das ist das Gerät, das wir in Amerika herstellen werden.
Ja gut, aber das hatte jetzt auch keiner ernsthaft bezweifelt.
Doch, Tim. Tim hat irgendwie von iPads und iPhones und was weiß ich nicht irgendwie spekuliert. Ja, hörst rein in die Sendung. Und so höher werden das für mich rausfinden.
Ja, das wüsste ich mal gern. Falls das jemand mal rauspuppeln kann, wo ich da eine falsche Aussage gemacht habe, ich lass mich gerne widerlegen. Am Ende stellt sich heraus, ich hatte Recht. Nicht Recht hatte ich mit dem Preis irgendwie. Ich dachte ja, es wird irgendwie billiger, aber nichtsdestotrotz haben sie das Teil.
Ich dachte, es wird teurer.
3000 Euro.
Dollar.
Dollar, genau. Sie schmeißen da wohl offensichtlich wirklich amtliche Grafikkarten rein. Das, wenn man jetzt nur die CPU und die Grafikchips zusammenzählt, schon auf nennenswerte Preise käme.
Was heißt dann amtliche Grafikkarten? Das würde mich ja mal interessieren.
AMD, ich kenne mich ja nicht aus bei Grafikkarten, deswegen kann ich da erst mal nur so am Rande sagen.
Moment, ich scrolle noch.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dann sind das halt diese, wie nennt man die, diese Profi-Grafikkarten. Und die Profi-Grafikkarten, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, das ist als alles Spekulieren und Hörensagen und korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch bin. Oder das machen die Hörer dann, wenn sie die Sendung hören. Ich will mal gleich den Chat nach vorne. Diese Chips, die da drinstecken, diesen Pro-Grafikkarten, sind die gleichen wie in den Konsumergeräten, nur dass die halt eine andere ID haben und von dem Treiber anders behandelt werden. Damit die dann, die sind nämlich dadurch dann wieder leicht langsamer, aber die rechnen halt mit einer hohen Genauigkeit, weil du beim Rendern halt das nicht gebrauche. Das muss halt immer gleich sein, muss immer perfekt sein. Und wenn du aber Spiele spielst, dann muss das nicht so sein. Und dann ist es ein Stück schneller, besser und ein bisschen ungenauer. Und das ist der Unterschied, weswegen du da mehr bezahlst. Weil die genauer rechnen. Genau, der Treiber schaltet um, alles klar. Da ist die ID der Pro-Grafikkarte und dann schalten sie auf hohe Genauigkeit. Und das ist das, was du beim Rendern brauchst. Und bei allen anderen Sachen, die halt so eine Grafikkarte da irgendwie benutzen. Wer auch immer so eine Grafikkarte benutzt, ist mir ja nicht so klar. Und dann sind das vielleicht einfach die neuen, die von AMD gerade kommen. Diese R9-Serie, weiß nicht so genau. Haben sie mich schon korrigiert? Ist das irgendwie schon meine Information überholt?
Nö, also Fire Pro.
Ich find aber amtlich schön.
D300, D500, D700 oder so war glaube ich die Staffelung.
Also hier haben sie nur noch den D300 und die D500 in den Tech-Specs.
Ja, auf jeden Fall geht es bei 3000 Dollar los. Dann habe ich mir überlegt, ok, angenommen, es gäbe irgendetwas an diesem Gerät, was mich jetzt echt rockt. Software kommt raus und alles funktioniert auf einmal 30 mal so schnell. Ableton Live kann 5 Stunden Podcast in 5 Sekunden rausrennen.
Ist da auch nur ein 6-fach Core?
Es ist nicht die CPU, sondern die OpenCL Performance.
Und das haben die auch bei deinem Audiokram?
Plugins nutzen so was bisweilen. Aber weder einen Überblick noch habe ich akuten Bedarf. Ich sage nur theoretisch angenommen, irgendetwas würde mich jetzt zacken. Bei diesem Mac Pro, wo alle da vorstehen und sagen, wie konnten wir ohne das leben und muss ich haben. Dann fängt man mal an zu rechnen. Was muss man denn alles kaufen? Also du kaufst dieses Gerät und du hast da noch nicht mal die Möglichkeit, Platten reinzuschubsen. Also kaufst du ja erstmal Plattenräd. Da kannst du jetzt irgendeinen PC, Höcker, irgendwie Flower Power billig SATA REC kaufen. Oder ganz Mac-User, wenn du eh schon Mac Pro hast, kaufst du ja dann so ein teures Pegasus.
Musste ja, weil selbst dann, das Ding hat das USB 3.
Sollte zumindest als Thunderbolt 2 geben. Ist gerade angekündigt worden gestern oder vorgestern. Thunderbolt 2. Pegasus gibt es jetzt demnächst mit Thunderbolt 2. Nicht nur mit Thunderbolt.
Da muss Apple ja dafür sorgen, dass es sowas gibt. Sonst lohnt sich ja der teure Kasten nicht.
Shiny Hotness. Und jetzt mit 8 Platten übrigens. Kannst du jetzt mit 8 x 4G bestückende Ding, also 32T da rein machen und die mit Thunderbolt 2 hinten andocken an deinen MacBook Air.
Also du musst ja auch so ein Ding nehmen, sonst lohnt sich die teure Kiste ja nicht. Also mit USB 3 brauchst du nicht kommen.
Ja, dann musst du noch deinen DVD-Laufwerk da anschließen.
Das kostet bei Apple einen Hunni, so diese externe DVD-Laufwerk.
Genau, nochmal ein Hunni.
Ey, was du bis jetzt nicht gerippt hast, rippst du doch auch nicht mehr.
Oder kannst du denn immer noch mit dem alten Rechner rippen?
Ja toll, ich kauf mir einen neuen Rechner, um den alten Rechner daneben zum Rippen noch zu betreiben.
Ey, du, wenn du Mac Pro hast und immer noch irgendwas mit Scheiben machst, dann brauchst du auch keinen neuen Mac Pro.
Die kannst du doch auf deinem Air rippen, also jetzt bitte.
Nein, da hat der auch keinen Laufwerk dran.
Ich hab das Ding da drin, ich benutze es, also muss ich es mitzählen. Wenn ich es nicht benutzen würde, würde ich nicht mitzählen. Ich benutze es aber.
Tja, dann bist du jetzt schon mal 3.100 Dollar.
Nee, dann ist noch dieser ganze Pegasus, tralala, nur damit ich ein paar Festplatten reinschieben kann.
Ich hab letztens noch gesagt, das ist ja so ein bisschen blöd mit dem Aufwinter, dass du sagt, das ist doch voll super, wenn alles extern ist, dann braucht man sich alle paar Jahre nur noch eine neue Tonne kaufen, hast du gesagt.
Ich hab nicht gesagt, dass es super ist, ich hab nur gesagt, dass es das Konzept, was Apple im Sinn hat. Und das mag für bestimmte Workstation-Setups auch der Weg sein, wenn ich an so eine große 3D-Bude denke, die einfach, was weiß ich, dreißig Arbeitsplätze. Naja, aber du weißt, was ich meine, für solche Setups, wo du wirklich diese Batterie, im wahrsten Sinne des Dinges, sieht aus wie so eine riesen Batterie, du tauschst einfach die Batterie und dann ist es irgendwie schneller und der Rest bleibt da.
Du meinst das, was man in den Flux-Kompensator reinsteckt, dieses Ding?
Ja, das anfängt eigentlich nicht arm. Ich weiß nicht, ich mag meinen Mac Pro.
Ich mag meinen Mac Pro.
Ich find das einfach eine geile Maschine und ich werd dem noch eine Weile anhängen, sofern er mich nicht verlässt.
Und du hast da schon SSDs drin? Hast du diese Karte da, diese Sonnenskarte?
Ja, so Platten, so Ka-Ching, mal eben so diesen Schieber da raus, machen Zack-Boom, Platte rein, Platte raus, super.
Ja, man kann auch mal gegentreten, außer sehen, weil man gerade irgendwie mit dem Stuhl durch...
Du kannst auch Baupacker, du kannst auch Ka-Ching machen. Im laufenden Betrieb sogar.
Ja, und dann auch die Ports ordentlich vorne, hinten und nicht dieses komische, eierige Drehe. Ich mein, du kannst diesen Mac Pro sowieso nicht drehen, weil wenn du da hinten erstmal Kabel dran hast und du drehst es dann nach vorne, dann ziehst du deine ganzen Plattenräder und du hast immer einen Tisch.
Na gut, ich bin auch noch nicht überzeugt.
Wir gucken uns das Ding mal an, wenn es da ist und dann kaufen wir uns den roten.
Genau, den einen.
So, nächstes Kapitel, liebe Show-Notes. iPad heißt das.
iPod Air, den hat es nie gegeben.
Zum Thema iPod, es gab keine neuen, nichts.
Na gut, aber die gibt es eh immer ein bisschen später.
Können sie verkaufen, glaube ich, 45 Millionen davon?
Nein, glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, dass sie gar keine neuen mehr rausbringen werden.
Also, was mal AirPods Classic genannt wurde irgendwann, den gibt es noch. Den gibt es noch, der wird auch noch verkauft, aber der wird, glaube ich, nie wieder ein Update sehen. Also da bin ich schwer pessimistisch.
Was sehr schade ist, ich wäre ja mal für eine Sonderedition. Ein iPhone, wo vorne der Touchscreen ist und auf der Rückseite ein Skrullwheel, ein Clickwheel. Ich meine das ernst.
Ja, ich fürchte.
Tim, das kann sein, dass es wieder Schuhversteller gibt, die dir sowas bauen. Die bauen dir nämlich wieder eine iPhone Hülle, wo so ein Skrullwheel hinten drauf ist.
Jetzt kommen wir auf einen interessanten Punkt. Darüber habe ich nämlich auch schon nachgedacht.
Smart Cover.
Wenn es das Clickwheel, das letzte heißt auch Clickwheel. Clickwheel ist das letzte, oder? Touchwheel, Skrullwheel, ich komm durcheinander. Das, was sie jetzt in dem aktuellen iPod Classic verkaufen. Das Teil als Bluetooth-Device, vielleicht noch hinten mit zwei, drei Buttons drauf. Als Fernsteuerung fürs iPhone. Hotness ensues.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Doch, das ist User-Interface-Porn.
Nehmt ihm das Bier weg.
Ich werde einfach, verstehst du? Jugenderinnerung, du kennst das doch so. Damals, Sommer, die anderen kleinen Mädchen, die fanden auch alle nackt über den Strand und du hattest dein Eis in der Hand und die Sonne schien. Alles war toll und ihr wart glücklich.
Und was war jetzt in der Story? Ist jetzt das Click-Wheel?
Naja, mir geht es so ein bisschen mit dem iPod 5. Generation. Einfach der Traum von Audiosteuerung.
Weil... Du hörst so ein bisschen die Bacardi-Musik im Hintergrund, oder was? Ich versuche gerade, das Bild, was du da... Am Strand.
Bacardi-Musik, genau.
Es riecht würzig.
Bacardi-Feeling.
Genau.
Ah, nein. Nein.
Doch. Du hast einfach das Teil, du greifst in deine Hose, klickst und scrollst, ja.
Rappierdick in der Rückblick? Nein, das war was anderes.
Müssen wir ihn nochmal klar machen? Genau. Und jetzt nimmst du den iPod 5G, gar nicht erst raus aus der Hosentasche, sondern du klickst einfach in die Mitte drauf und es macht Pause. Und dann scrollst du ein paar Sekunden zurück. Und da kannst du weitermachen. Ah, cool, jetzt hab ich das auch mal gehabt. Und du kannst es ja auch mitten im Betrieb machen, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Also es war einfach schnell, du findest die Stellen schnell, du kannst dynamisch vor uns zurückspulen, super. Also für Podcasts, top, müsste man nur jemand mal, keine Ahnung, die alten iPods auf dem Markt aufkaufen und dann einfach rausbauen, das Clickwheel und Bluetooth ausstatten.
Den Rest hinten wegfräsen. Der CNC-Fräse, alles hinter dem Clickwheel wegfräsen.
Schön war's.
Übrigens bei so Sachen, ich wollte gerade noch viel mehr ein, weil du nämlich jetzt nochmal iPhone erwähnt hast, aber es gibt natürlich noch eine Sache, die im MacBook Pro, Pro, ich sag nochmal MacBook Pro, immer noch fehlt. Ein fucking Slot, wo ich eine SIM-Karte reinmachen kann, damit das eingebaute LTE-Modem mich mit dem Internet verbindet. Ich find das so peinlich. Jeder dumme Drecks-China-PC im Saturn hat inzwischen so ein Mobilfunk-Modem drin. Jetzt vielleicht nicht LTE, aber mindestens 3G.
Aber deswegen sind es auch scheiß Drecks-China-PCs, weil die jeden Scheiß drin haben, den keiner braucht.
Ach, und warum braucht man das nicht? Wir hatten eine Diskussion doch schon mal.
LTE-Modem.
Ja, man kann mit deinem iPhone tazern. Ja, für eine halbe Stunde, weil das ist nämlich meine scheiß Batterie, alle.
Aber du kannst doch dein iPhone an der Mac Pro Engelstar laden.
Aber warum soll man das tun? Nein, ich möchte jetzt bitte schön diesen Scheiß-Sport haben. Wenn das so wäre, dann würden nicht diese ganzen Gänsefüßchen Business-PCs, die ganzen Zinkpads, die Samsungs, die Sonys und diesen ganzen Scheiß schon seit Jahren haben. Und nochmal, Apple hat eine eigene Scheiß-Abteilung dafür für den ganzen Quack. Die haben diese ganze, die haben sogar Test-Equipment, weil sie bauen ja Telefone für GSM und 3G und LTE und CDMA und Lalalala und Pipapo. Die haben alle da, die haben ihre Labore da, die haben die Entwickler da, die wissen, wie das geht. Wo ist das Problem jetzt da, bitte diese kleine Scheiß-Mobilfunkmodem damit einzubauen? Meinetwegen auch nur in die Pro-Version. Die Leute, die gerne Facebook klicken im Café und Latte dabei schlürfen, die können das mit dem MacBook eher machen, da brauchst du einen Scheiß nicht. Aber für einen fucking Pro will ich diesen SIM-Card-Slot da drin haben. Bitte, endlich!
Clemens, kann ich dich daran erinnern, dass du, glaube ich, letzte Sendung gesagt hast, du willst das iPhone 5S nicht haben, weil dieses ganze LTE-Gedönst, du in Deutschland sowieso keinen Vertrag kriegst, wo du da irgendwie ausreichend Daten mitmachen könntest?
Ja, aber ich bin ja nicht immer in Deutschland, wie du weißt.
Und meine schwedische SIM-Karte macht das super.
Ja, und die Zeiten werden sich auch noch ändern. Nee, also ich bin da ganz bei dir. Ich hatte das schon wieder fast vergessen. Man wird ja so unterwürfig, dass man...
Wieso, man kann sich einen USB-Dongle da dran machen oder mit seinem iPhone tessern?
Ich will aber, warum soll ich tessern? Das Problem mit tessern ist, dass der Rechner dann selber keinerlei Vorstellungen davon hat, ob er mit einem 3G Netz verbunden ist oder nicht.
Aber wir reden jetzt von einem Mac Pro, nicht von einem Laptop.
Nein, MacBook Pro.
Ich will das auch an meinem Air haben. Warum sollte in ein Air keine Nano-SIM-Karte reinpassen? Kannst du mir das mal erklären? Ich meine, wenn sie das in ein iPhone rein kriegen, dann kriegen sie das ja wohl mal locker in so eine dicke Flunda rein. Ich meine, sie kriegen es ja auch in ein iPad rein. Where is the fucking difference? Nur das OS. Nur weil sie Angst haben, dass die Leute von ihren Datentarifen vergewaltigt werden.
Naja, jetzt haben sie mit Mavericks erstmal das mit der Energie gefixt. Vielleicht fixen sie das mit dem Netzwerk auch. Dann gibt es dann als nächstes den, den diese App verbraucht gerade am meisten Netzwerk. Irgendwie Prange.
Und LTE ist leer.
Funktioniert das eigentlich mit VPN und IPv6 jetzt richtig, Clemens?
Ähm, ich hab ja wie gesagt, meine Mavericks Installation ist nur auf einer Wirtln-Maschine, aber da könnte ich ja mal einen VPN mal öffnen, um das auszuprobieren.
Was hat die eigentlich geritten, das iPad jetzt iPad Air zu nennen?
Weil es zu leicht ist.
Ich finde, das ist so ein bekloppten Namen. Das hat es jetzt echt nicht nötig gehabt.
Vielleicht kommt demnächst das iPad Pro.
Hm, du mich auch. Das stelle ich dann neben mein Surface zu Hause auf den Schreibtisch.
Das benutzt du als Schreibtisch, weil da eine 47 Zoll Variante rauskommt.
Genau. Nee, dann lieber gleich eine Paint Station. Naja, wie auch immer.
Tja, ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht gibt es ja noch mal einen Markt für ein großes iPad.
Ja, also dieser R Zusatz, der ist echt so ein, das ist so ein Marketing Gag, oder? Also, das ist alles total schlimm.
Sie haben iPad, iPad 2, dann haben sie das iPad gar nicht genannt.
The New iPad und dann iPad Fourth Generation. Ja, jetzt heißt es iPad R. Was ist das nächste? Vista? Oder was?
Naja, sie versuchen halt darauf hinzuweisen, dass das Ding eben jetzt eine andere Bauform hat. Hat's ja auch. Ich meine, das ist das erste iPad, was mit dem traditionellen Verhältnis von Bildschirm und Rahmen bricht.
Und weil es eigentlich ein großes Mini ist.
Außerdem ist es noch sehr leicht und es wiegt nur, wie viel? 500 Gramm?
Tick unter den Pfund, haben sie gesagt.
467 oder so.
Pfund, weiß doch kein Mensch, was ein Pfund ist.
Klar, ein halber Kilo.
Ja, den ist doch immer alle mit.
Das ist ein amerikanisches Pfund. Ja, das ist kein Euro Pfund. Ich schau mal.
467. Oder 76.
iPad-R. Jetzt muss man hier erst mal lange suchen, bis man hier Specs findet.
Bis man Speck findet.
469 in der WLAN-Variante und...
9 Gramm mehr mit...
Krass.
Das ist die SIM-Karte. Die wiegt 9 Gramm.
Das interessante ist, dass das Retina Mini, also das iPad Mini, ist ja schwerer jetzt durch den neuen Bildschirm, als das...
Nein, das ist nicht schwerer.
Als das alte Mini.
Schwerer als das alte Mini.
Nicht schwerer als das eher.
Nee, hab ich nicht gesagt. Das ist der Vorgänger. Das Ding ist ja jetzt deutlich leichter geworden, aber das Retina Mini ist ein paar Gramm. 330 Gramm oder so. Also 330 und das große 478. Da ist nicht mehr viel Abstand. Also ich schätze mal, es kann gut sein, dass das neue im Verhältnis zu seiner Größe irgendwie genauso leicht wirkt. Also es ist nicht als schwerer wahrnimmst, weil es auch sich auf eine andere Dimension verteilt. Wird spannend zu sehen. Wann gibt's das? Nächste Woche? Übermorgen. Auch dann prügeln sie sich hier am Kuhdamm wieder?
November oder?
Oder 3. November? November. Freitag, alles klar. Wollen wir mal in den Apple Store gehen zusammen und da mal aufräumen? Könnten wir mal einen kleinen Ausflug machen. Einen kleinen Betriebsausflug. Können wir ein paar Geräte in die Hand nehmen? Was gibt es denn alles in die Hand nehmen? Aber das Mini gibt es ja auch noch nicht. Mac Pro gibt es auch noch nicht. Was sollen wir denn da in die Hand nehmen?
Meinst du nicht, dass sie solange sie es nicht verkaufen, haben sie den Kram auch nicht da? Oder wie ist das?
Nein.
Obwohl da hätten sie am ersten Tag gleich die 5S wieder wegräumen müssen.
Die kriegen es immer in der Nacht vorher. Die schieben echt Nachtschichten dort. Die kriegen es in der Nacht vorher, bauen es dann alles hin und so. Und dann...
Also, da müssen wir noch ein bisschen warten, bis alles da ist. Ich warte jetzt auch noch, bis alles da ist. Dann geh ich dann mal wieder vorbei und guck mir das mal an. Ja, da hab ich ja... Ich war ja eigentlich sehr davon überzeugt, dass ich mir sofort ein iPad Mini kaufe, sobald es als Rädchener da ist. Da hab ich die Preise gesehen. Das bin ich mir nicht mehr zu sicher.
Das ist nochmal teurer geworden.
Aber du hast doch gesagt, du wolltest die alten iPad Mini kaufen.
Ja, wenn die mal richtig billig sind.
Achso, du meinst nicht die Gebrauchten, sondern von Apple?
Ich nehm sie auch gerne gebraucht, aber ich denke, die Gebrauchtpreise dürften jetzt noch in keinem nennenswerten Bereich sein, wenn das Ding gerade mal 30 Euro billiger geworden ist.
Du kannst ja so ein cheapo bille China-Ding holen. Da ist dann auch so ein SIM-Karten-Ding drin.
Mhm, mich auch. Ja, aber auf jeden Fall, feine Hardware hier mit diesen ganzen 64-Bit-Klimb-Bim fänd ich schon geil. Also, dass sie auch irgendwie alles gespendet haben.
Aber krass ist, dass sie das alte iPad noch verkaufen mit dem alten 30-Pin-Connector.
Das ist echt frech.
Da hätte ich ja gedacht, dass sie das irgendwie einstampfen.
Ja, vor allem für 400 Euro.
Naja, scheinbar können sie das...
Also, ich meine...
Scheinbar können sie das Teil irgendwie zu Nullkosten produzieren und zu Goldstaubpreisen verkaufen. Also, ich meine, da würde ich es auch am Programm lassen. Wahrscheinlich verkaufen die pro Quartal mehr iPad 2 als Microsoft insgesamt Surface verkauft hat.
Ja, aber wenn ich mir jetzt so ein iPad Mini kaufen würde, weißt du, dann willst du ja erstmal Rädchen haben. Da bist du schon mal bei 400 Euro. Dann willst du natürlich irgendwie Speicher haben.
Wie viel?
Naja, es gibt halt 128.
Naja, ich hab's jetzt mit 32 GIG, das ist ein bisschen knappig.
Warum? Also mir reichen die 64.
Warum, dass es knapp ist? Also ich hab 32 auf dem Telefon und das meiste geht fast für Bilder drauf. Und ich würde sagen, dass ich mit dem iPad nicht so viele Bilder mache.
Naja, Podcasts ist so ein bisschen das Problem. Was ich da momentan hab, ist, dass ich eigentlich auf dem iPad will ich eigentlich die ganzen Videopodcasts haben. Und auf dem iPhone will ich eigentlich alle Audiopodcasts haben. So, und jetzt synchronisieren die aber alle wild untereinander. Und das heißt, ich hab mit allen Clients, die ich so hab, irgendwie alle Podcasts auf allen Geräten. Und ich denk mir immer so, Scheiße, was soll das? So irgendwie so...
Podcasts, Statistiken taugen bald auch nix mehr.
Ich muss es echt irgendwie stärker aufräumen und sagen, der Kleine kriegt jetzt die Art von Podcasts und der Kleine kriegt jetzt die Art von Podcasts. Weil da scheint irgendwie keiner dran gedacht zu haben, dass ich halt von manchen Geräten bestimmte Arten haben will. Also Video und auf dem anderen Audio irgendwie.
Ja, das wäre mal ein schönes Feature.
Vielleicht sollten einfach alle User, die so ein Problem haben, sich eine zweite Apple-ID anlegen. Wenn Apple dann merkt, dass alle Leute zwei oder drei oder vier Apple-IDs haben, dann werden sie das Problem dann doch langsam mal sehen, nicht mögen und lösen. Weil das hassen die bestimmt, wenn alle Leute Doppel-IDs machen.
Und warum du noch relativ viel Speicher im iPad haben willst, ist, weil wenn man spielt, dann ist es einfach auf dem iPad cooler. Und so die ganzen coolen Spiele sind halt relativ groß. Unter einem Geek kriegst du halt kaum noch was. Und dann hast du noch Karten. Karten sind auch relativ nett. Also ich würde auch jederzeit wieder eins mit...
Du meinst so Navi-Zeugs?
Ja, ja, mit Cellular-Namen. Und dann hast du da dein, wie hieß das Ding? Dieses, äh, Ding Map 2. Forever Map 2. Genau, da lädst du einmal Deutschland runter. Das sind schon mal irgendwie 800 Megabyte. Ja, oder 700. Und dann lädst du irgendwie noch Großbritannien und noch Holland runter und dann bist du, weißt du, bist du schon wieder bei 1,5 Gig.
Schweden nicht vergessen.
Schweden nicht vergessen, genau. Und dann willst du, in dem Gerät willst du dann schon relativ viel Speicher haben und deswegen finde ich 32 Gig halt ein bisschen knapp für ein iPad.
Ja, heißt mit LTE, Tralala, Klimbim, 74 Gigabyte, Retina bist du bei 689 Euro. Und dann dachte ich mir so, eine Geräteklasse, die du normalerweise gar nicht benutzt.
689, nee, was?
Ja, 64 Gigabyte mit Cellular.
Mit Cellular?
Kostet 689. Und das rechts unten Modell mit 128 Gigabyte. Was ja insofern auch das sinnvollste Gerät wäre, wenn du nach dem Nutzen gehst, weil du zahlst ja immer 100 Euro mehr für die Verdopplung des Speichers, das heißt erst im letzten. 90 Euro.
Nur von 32 auf 64 wollen sie 100 haben.
90. Von 599 auf 689. Und dann auf 799.
Ja, es sind immer 90 Euro. Stimmt schon.
Ich hab doch vorhin noch geguckt.
Ja, aber falsch.
Es sind halt 100 Dollar, aber 90 Euro.
Also bei dem Nicht-Cellular-Gerät.
Ja, da, Nicht-Cellular hab ich geguckt, genau. Da wären es genau 100 mehr von 32 nach 64. Und die anderen sind auch 90.
Und auch 99.
69, achso 59 da. Da hab ich tatsächlich falsch geguckt.
Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall.
Du kriegst immer das Doppelte für einen festen Preis. Das heißt, du kriegst eigentlich immer mehr fürs Geld.
Das heißt, ganz unten kriegst du für 90 Euro 16 GB dazu, wenn du es 32 nimmst. Und ganz oben kriegst du 64 GB dazu, wenn du von 64 auf 128 gehst.
Sie haben kein 256er-Gerät im Programm.
Damit du also nichts verschwendest, musst du eigentlich 780 Euro ausgeben. Aber 780 Euro für so ein kleines Teil? Da fragt man sich halt auch wieder.
Ja, dann vielleicht doch das iPad Air anklicken.
Ja, es gibt ja dann... Ja, aber das iPad Air kann ich halt nicht mitnehmen. Das ist einfach zu drummig.
120 Euro für den kleinen scheiß fucking SIM-Slot, ja?
Der SIM-Slot hat aber noch den Effekt, dass du ein GPS-Signal hast. Das hast du im Cellular nicht.
Das ganze WLAN-Zeugs und so hast du auch genug GPS oder also Position-Zeug.
Also ein tragbares Gerät ohne GPS.
Also aus eigener Erfahrung kann ich sagen, immer nur mit Cellular. Gerade wenn du im Ausland bist und du hast deine Offline-Map dabei und du hast da ein ordentliches Display, wo du auf der Straße sehen kannst, wo du hier lang musst. Das ist echt viel wert. Da würde ich nicht wieder von zurückweichen. Ein iPhone mit 128 GB wäre eigentlich noch sinnvoller, aber sowas gibt es ja nicht. Ich bin mit 64 GB eigentlich immer noch ganz zufrieden. Aber keine Ahnung.
Jetzt können wir noch ein bisschen über iWork abranten.
Ehrlich gesagt kann ich da nicht so richtig viel ranten, weil ich es nicht so richtig doll benutzt habe. Das Einzige, was mich ein bisschen nervt, ist, dass die neuen Versionen von iWork irgendwie nur unter Mavericks laufen. Das heißt, auf einem Rechner kann ich die nicht benutzen. Dem Arbeitsrechner, der ist nämlich noch nicht unter Mavericks. Da die aber hin und her und vor und zurück sünden und wenn du einmal ein Dokument angefasst hast mit der neuen Version, kannst du es mit der alten nicht mehr aufmachen. Das ist ein bisschen bekloppt. Ansonsten die weggenommenen Features, so doll hab ich es dann auch nicht verwendet bisher, dass ich da jetzt irgendwie größeres...
Na eins der Features, was gegangen ist, war für mich das wichtigste Feature überhaupt. Und einer der Gründe, warum ich Numbers benutzt habe. Und das ist jetzt weg.
Aber übrigens, wenn du guckst, im deutschen Store hat Numbers irgendwie zweieinhalb Stern. Durchschnittliches Review. Also für die aktuelle Version, ne? Also das trifft die noch härter als hier dieses Video-Ding. Wie ist das? Final Cut Pro. Naja, das andere verkaufen sie im Prinzip auch. Also du kriegst es zu neuen Geräten dazu. Aber du kannst es updaten.
Kauft auch keiner mehr nach groß. Also ja, ich hab halt diese Kategorien verwendet wie Sau. Das ist für mich das Orga-Tool überhaupt in diesen Spreadsheets. Und das ist jetzt weg. Ja, Kategorien.
Weiß ich nicht, was das ist, aber...
Wenn du eine Tabelle hast und diese Tabelle beinhaltet zum Beispiel eine Spalte mit einem Datum, dann kannst du mit diesen Kategorien, dann sagst du, sortier mir das nach Kategorien. Dann kannst du sagen, sortier mir das nach dieser Datums-Spalte. Und unabhängig davon, welche Reihenfolge die Zellen normalerweise haben, sortiert er dir das Ding jetzt nach Datum, aber er gruppiert es nach Datum. Und du kannst einstellen, nach wie genau. Also im Falle von Datum bedeutet das zum Beispiel, ich könnte sagen, gruppier es mir nach Jahreszahl. Und dann hab ich, wie bei so einer Outline, so ein Disclosure Triangle, alle Records, die in 2013 sind. Alle Records, die in 2012 sind. Und ich kann aber auch sagen, auf der zweiten Ebene, auch nach Datum, aber nach Quartal. Und in der dritten Spalte, wieder nach Datum, aber nach Monat. Das heißt, ich hab quasi aus meinem Spreadsheet eine Outline gemacht. Und ohne, dass ich irgendwas ändern muss und ohne, dass sich auch irgendetwas ändert an meiner Tabelle, ist es nur ein anderer View da drauf. Also es ist ein reines Display-Feature. Aber es ist so dermaßen überzeugend und einleuchtend, wenn du das einmal benutzt hast. Das ist einfach... Ich wüsste gar nicht, wie ich das sonst machen sollte. Wie soll ich sonst in so einer Liste Quartals-Zusammenfassungen machen?
Aber sortieren nach einer Spalte geht schon noch, oder?
Ja, du sortierst, aber du kannst halt nichts auseinanderklappen und du kannst keine Subsummen bilden. Also ich kann dann auch in dieser... Da erscheint dann so eine virtuelle Zeile an der Stelle und ich kann dann sagen, fass hier alle Werte in einer anderen Spalte zusammen als Summe, als Average, Durchschnitt, was auch immer. So, und so kann ich dann halt Zusammenfassungen nach Quartal, nach Monat und so weiter machen, ohne jetzt hier groß mit irgendwelchen Formel-Klimpen kommen zu müssen. Also ich sag einfach, nur kategorisier mir das und fertig.
Ich glaube, dass sie das wahrscheinlich unterschätzt haben und dadurch, dass sie jetzt ordentlich auf Ömme kriegen, wahrscheinlich da auch nochmal zurückrudern werden.
Nee, und ich dachte ja, warum?
Warum?
Na, weil sie jetzt nur noch Sachen machen, die auch auf dem iPad implementierbar sind. Das heißt, du wirst jetzt in diesem Numbers überhaupt keine Desktop-Class-Features mehr kriegen, wenn das nicht auch touchable ist.
Aber du hast doch viele Sachen, hast du doch in dem Numbers für iPad auch drin gehabt.
Ja, aber es war nicht kompatibel zueinander. Es war was anderes.
Ich hab das vorher irgendwie über iCloud ausgetauscht und miteinander verwendet und Zeug.
Ja, aber da ist zum Beispiel keine Kategorien da. Mit diesen Kategorien, das ist wieder so ein Ding, das muss man mal gemacht haben und dann, wenn man das Licht gesehen hat, dann ist man ärgerlich, wenn es aus ist.
Also ich meine, wenn nicht, dann halt nicht. Also es wäre schade, wenn man jetzt irgendwie Excel benutzen müsste. Oder bewahre irgendwie Open Office Kalk oder so.
Ja, das ist alles ganz furchtbar. So, wollen wir zumachen hier den ganzen Apple-Karton? Das ist auch langweilig irgendwie.
Eben.
Uns wird schon noch was einfallen und dann streuen wir es halt wieder ein, da kennen wir ja nichts.
Alle mal in Store reinmaschinen, das wäre schon mal relativ lustig. Dann müssen wir allerdings irgendwie so ein Mobile-Aufzeichnungsgerät dabei haben, müssen wir mal gucken.
Ja, dann machen wir einen Flashmob.
Was Google Glass bräuchte man dann?
Übermorgen oder wie?
Übermorgen ist ja noch nicht da, was man kaufen möchte.
Den Mac Pro oder was?
Den Mac Pro muss er schon stehen, finde ich.
Aber das war erst im Dezember.
Du meinst, wir kaufen einfach alles, Clemens, oder was?
Ja, wir gehen einfach mal hin und sagen...
Wir hätten es gerne.
Ohne kaufen. Geld spielt keine Rolle.
Sonst rennen wir direkt im Laden los.
Okay, jetzt hier nächste Thema. Bitcoin. Was soll das heißen? 2S? Verstehe nicht.
Du machst den Bitcoin. Du weißt nicht, was eine OO's ist?
OO's? Börsenfernsehen? Ich glaube, das gucken Leute, die gerne Bitcoins hätten.
Bullenmarkt und Bärenmarkt. Genau. Also eine OO's ist anhaltend steigende Kurse und eine BÄS ist ein anhalt-sinkender Kurs. Beziehungsweise anhalt-sinkend Kurse. Das ist sozusagen das Auf und Nieder des Aktienmarktes.
Ich hab mich nie so mit beschäftigt.
Eine OO's ist sozusagen, wenn die Kurse gehen. Och! Und wenn ich mal gucke hier bei Bitcoin.
Und eine BÄS ist, wenn Kurse gehen badly in den Keller?
Ja, also ich hatte mal so testweise ein paar Verkaufsaufträge gemacht. Oder nennt man das dann? Eine Order, genau. Um da mal so ein bisschen mit rumzuspielen. Da kommt man ja dann so ein bisschen in Versuchung. Und dabei ist mir überhaupt erst aufgefallen...
Direkt auf die Grafik klicken?
Dass der Preis dann doch etwas angestiegen ist, so im Zeitraum der letzten drei, vier, fünf, sechs Monate. Also da ist doch schon wieder einiges getan. Nachdem wir... Wann war die letzte... Der letzte Peak war April, Mai letzten Jahres.
Mitte April letzten Jahres, genau. Da ging er bis 200 Euro circa hoch. Da war er aber auch wirklich nur ganz kurz, für so ein paar Stunden. Ich weiß nicht, für wie lange wirklich. Und ist ja dann noch tierisch abgecrashed, bis auf ja 120, 180 ging er dann teilweise bis auf 40 runter. Irgendwie 40, 50 Euro runter. Und dann hat sich's ja wieder gefangen und ist seitdem ein bisschen hin und her geeiert und hat sich so in letzter Zeit so zwischen 80, 90, 100, so seit September eingepegelt.
Genau und ich hab da ja zufällig davon mitbekommen, weil ich hatte mal so ein paar optimistische Verkäufe angesetzt, um das mal so zu testen und gesagt so, ja bei 120, 130, 140, 150 verkaufe man mal irgendwas. So nach dem Motto, wenn man das schon triggert, dann sollte auch was bei rumkommen. Und bin aber jetzt nicht davon ausgegangen, dass in den nächsten zwei Jahren da irgendwas passiert. Ja und siehe da, auf einmal war irgendwie alles verschabelt. Ja ja, also ich hab zum Beispiel da irgendwie so einen kleinen Charge für 150 Euro verbringt.
Eine Tranche, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Eine Tranche oder eine Tranche in der OO's.
Ja und jetzt sind sie alle weg und jetzt ärgerst du dich, weil es weiter gestiegen ist.
Eine Tranche in der Hauserle.
Nein, jetzt ärgert er sich, dass der Mac Pro noch nicht zu kaufen ist.
Ja, meine Tranche in der Hauserle, die ist dann weggegangen. Da musste ich mir überlegen, jetzt könnte ich ja los spekulieren und sagen, okay, ich kauf mir dann mein Bitcoinchen wieder zurück, wenn es wieder gefallen ist. Richtig rumspekulieren.
Aber ist nicht wieder gefallen?
Wollt nicht. Nicht sehr bisher. Aber ich kann ja so einen Order da reinstellen und dann macht er das dann halt irgendwann und ich muss mir da nicht immer groß drum kümmern. Macht man das so? Wird man so weich?
Keine Ahnung. Ich bin nicht so der Börsenzocker. Ich kauf immer und lasse ihn.
Du bist mehr so Dagobert, ne? Du lässt einfach die Goldstücke in den Speicher rein und dann schwimmst du da und bist glücklich und es ist dir scheißegal, wie der Kurs da draußen ist.
Das ist ein sehr guter Entgelt. Kann man halt nicht schwimmen.
Ja, aber das muss doch unheimlich schmerzhaft sein. Ich hab mir immer gedacht, wenn Dagobert da so vom 3-Meter-Brett auf das blanke Silber und Gold hüpft, das muss doch unglaublich weh tun.
Gold ist ziemlich weich.
Wenn du die ganzen Dinge richtig gelesen hättest, wüsstest du auch, dass nur Dagobert das kann. Es gibt nämlich immer mal wieder Leute, die das regelmäßig probieren und sich da richtig blaue Flecken beiholen. Und das Dagobert, weil der sein Ein und Alles ist, ist seine Fähigkeit, ist seine Superkraft, dass er in so große Berge von Gold und Goldbarren schwimmt ja zwischen den Münzen immer noch Goldbarren rum. Und er kann da eintauchen und durch und wieder raus hupfen.
Teilweise sind die aber dann auch in Säcke verpackt. Also einzelne Goldsäcke sind da auch immer drin.
Es gibt auch mal irgendwelche Stories, wo irgendwelche Leute da mal reinhupfen. Manchmal sieht man auch Fremde darin baden, aber es gibt auch Stories, wo Donald zum Beispiel versucht da reinzuhupfen und dann immer nur blau lidiert wieder rauskommt. Aber irgendwie, ich eigentlich, ob das jetzt schädlich ist oder nicht, sind sie sich nicht geworden.
Ja, mit Donald wird das nichts mit Bitcoins. Dennis badet mit Bitcoins. Die gehen auch butterweich.
Virtuell.
Du bist gar nicht Millionär. Ich dachte, wir können uns hier ordentlich an dich ranwanzen so jetzt über die Jahre.
Jetzt hab ich die Ansage gemacht, dass wir in den Apple Store gehen und den leer kaufen. Und jetzt, was ist jetzt, Dennis? Ich komme mir jetzt vor, wie diese, die Yvonne aus der Olsen-Bande, die immer hingeht, sagt, ja Egon, jetzt hast du hier tolle Sachen versprochen. Und was ist jetzt? Wir können doch da jetzt nicht in den Store gehen und du hast kein Geld, Dennis.
Tja, I'm very sorry. Was war der Standardsport von der Olsen-Bande immer?
Mächtig gewaltig, Egon. Mächtig gewaltig, Clemens.
Ja, aber diese Anstieg bei den Bitcoins gerade, wie wir ja sehen, die sind jetzt bei was? 150 irgendwas, vor einer Woche oder so, hat es ja dann kurzfristig auch mal plopp gemacht und ist jetzt ja bis auf 130 wieder runtergefallen. Irgendwer hat sich dann gedacht, oh meine Fresse, 167 Euro waren die letzte Woche mal ganz kurz. Das ist ja aber dann doch ganz schön viel Geld und muss richtig viele verkauft haben, weil es ist wirklich gleich mal um 30, 35 Euro gefallen.
Immer die nervös Werder.
Ja, aber das müsstest du doch dann am Handelsvolumen sehen. Das ist ja bei zwei Parametern, also den Preis und den Volumen.
Wenn jemand nicht sich ausgezockt hätte, müsstest du doch was sehen da. Ich geh mal bei den US-Dollars, gehe ich mal rein, klick da mal und dann hier zehn Tage, wartet letzte Woche, ja da wart, genau. Das war hier am 24. irgendwie so und es wurden verkauft. Also muss natürlich einer gewesen sein, aber hier einer, ein Balken hier zeigt über 20.000 an. Und der zweite daneben zeigt 8.000 an. Also man kann so von 30.000 Bitcoins ausgehen, die dann in relativ kurzer Zeit verhökert wurden oder ihren Besitzer wechselten. Und sonst waren es eher immer so unter 2.000. Also 15-facher...
5 Millionen Euro sind es dann, ne?
Ja, 15-facher Verkauf als wie sonst. Das ist schon was.
Gewinnmitnahme.
Hat sich auch wieder eingepegelt.
In meiner Twitter-Timeline hab ich irgendwie was gesehen, heute oder gestern, dass es jetzt irgendwie einen Geldautomaten gibt, der mit Bitcoins arbeitet. Hatte jemand von euch gesagt.
Wo war das? In Zypern, wie angeblich oder sowas. Aber, ja.
Aber was heißt jetzt Geldautomat da? Ich kann da hingehen und der Ding...
Der kann wahrscheinlich in beide Richtungen. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie gut wir den Automaten gemacht haben, aber wenn er gut ist, dann geht es in beide Richtungen. Wenn es ein Change-Automat ist...
Dann schieb ich da Scheine rein und der taucht auf meinem Bitcoin-Konto auf.
Du schiebst da eine Scheine rein und sagst bitte auf diese Adresse überweisen und dann kommt es an. Oder du sagst hier... Der sagt, was seine Adresse ist. Also der weiß, welche Adresse der Automat selber hat. Oder gibt dir eine vor. Du kannst dann an die Adresse hin überweisen und dann spuckt er dir irgendwie Bargeld aus. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die das implementiert haben.
Eine Frage dazu. Da ich das Zeug nur theoretisch kenne und ich selber praktisch benutze im täglichen... Bisher muss ich mir mal überlegen, ob ich das mal mache. Wie sind jetzt eigentlich so aktuelle Transaktionszeiten damit?
Welche Transaktionszeiten meinst du? Wenn du von einer Währung in die andere wechselst? Oder wenn du einem von mir zu dir irgendwie eine Bitcoin-Transaktion machst?
Von mir zu dir oder so.
Na die passiert eigentlich sofort von... Also bis sie ins Netz geschoben ist oder bis sie weltweit rum ist, dauert so ein paar Sekunden irgendwie. Aber bis sie halt für dich... Also wenn ich dir was rüberschiebe und du mir das auch glauben kannst, dass ich das wirklich gemacht habe und meine Bitcoins nicht noch gleichzeitig an jemand anderen schiebe, das dauert halt sechs Blöcke immer. Man soll sechs Blöcke warten und da ja ein Block im Durchschnitt zehn Minuten dauert, sind es eigentlich nach einer Stunde.
Theoretisch.
Du kannst mir aber auch schon nach einem Block trauen, weil... Du kannst mir aber auch schon nach einem Block trauen, weil...
So ungefähr, ja.
Klingt nicht verlockend, wa?
Können wir jetzt wieder passend zum Intro heute nochmal? Gefällt ihnen das?
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem ganz cool, weil machst du es mit der Bank, dauert es irgendwie eine Woche. Außer du bist bei der gleichen Bank und überhaupt und tralala und dann hast du Glück, dass es gleich noch am gleichen Tag passiert.
Die Banken haben schon zugelegt, also...
Naja, nicht wirklich. Na, dann überweis mal zu mir einen Cent und dann gucken wir mal, wie lange der braucht.
Na, einen Tag braucht er schon.
Die Bank gewinnt immer.
Und einen Tag braucht er, wenn du den einen Tag morgens machst, dann ist es vielleicht am nächsten Tag abends da. Aber mach mal abends um halb sechs eine Überweisung.
Ja, aber das waren auch schon mal drei Tage.
Ja, klar, aber es dauert eigentlich immer noch viel zu lange.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich.
Inzwischen hat doch jeder Nerd sowieso ein DKB-Konto und was du zwischen DKB-Konten hin und her kopierst, geht sofort.
Was denn das?
Das sind die ganzen Sparbrötchen, die keine Gebühren zahlen wollen und an jedem Geldautomat Geld abheben wollen und bla. Ich hab ein DKB-Konto und werd immer gelinkelig von Ostland angefeindet, weil ich ein DKB-Konto habe. Weil, ist nämlich wohl dem Vernehmen nach die Nachfolgebank der Bank der DDR. Ja, erzählen mir so Leute, die sagen, ja, bist du bei einer Stasi-Bank? Ist ja eigentlich cool, weil die haben dann schon gut gewusst, wie man auch Dinge aufpasst und so. Und was ja für eine Bank kein schlechtes Ding ist, aber finde ich irgendwie ein bisschen komisch. Es gibt Leute, die sind seit Jahrzehnten bei der Deutschen Bank und werden nicht angefeindet. Und nur weil ich ein armer kleines Sparbrötchen bin und irgendwie so ein Billigkonto habe, muss mich dann von Ostlern anmaulen lassen, dass ich bei einer Stasi-Bank bin.
Das fällt dir ein, Clemens.
Na, ich mach. Wie kannst du das nur unterstützen?
Auf jeden Fall, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf in meiner totalen Unkenntnis, sieht nicht so aus, als ob der Bitcoin-Kurs bald wieder auf die Beträge abstürzt, mit denen er mal angefangen hat.
Na, ich denke, dass der jetzt so steigt, solange die NSA nicht ordentlich eingreift, würde ich sagen nein.
Gibt es doch diese Fonds in den USA, irgendwelche Firmen, die halt für kleine Anleger irgendwie denen ermöglichen, dass du kannst dann deine 10.000 Dollar hinschieben und musst dich halt mit Bitcoin nicht auseinandersetzen und die kaufen dir 10.000 Dollar dann aber Bitcoins ein. Und die haben eine Genehmigung bekommen als offizielles Business, aber nur mit Leuten, die wohl ein Mindestkapital von einer Million haben oder irgendwie so und die Maximalmenge, die man einsetzen darf, sind auch wirklich nur 10.000 Dollar, also gar nicht so viel, weil die wahrscheinlich meinten, dass Bitcoins noch so ein High-Risk-Business ist und die Leute da nicht pleite gehen, weil wenn du eine Million hast, dann ist es wahrscheinlich egal, ob da 10.000 fehlen irgendwie so.
Und die machen jetzt da richtig, du bei denen da dein Geld anlegen. Und die müssen natürlich jetzt, wenn Leute das machen, müssen Bitcoins kaufen dafür. Und deswegen kann sein, dass der Kurs jetzt hochgeht. Was hast du gerade gesagt?
Nachdem der amerikanische Staat jetzt selber im Besitz von Bitcoins ist, im Wert von mehreren Millionen, die sie ja bei Silk Road abgegriffen haben, können sich überlegen, wie viel war das, 1600 Bitcoins oder was hatten sie bei denen gefunden?
Wie viel? 16.000? Ja, keine Ahnung.
Haben sie die wirklich?
Na, sagte man so. Aber wie viel sollt ihr haben? 16.000 Bitcoins, mal 200 Dollar?
Die haben das geschrieben im Wert von mehreren Millionen Dollar. Haben sie geschrieben, aber das weiß man jetzt natürlich auch nicht.
Ja, aber es ist doch auch Peanuts im Gesamtmarkt.
Du wüsstest ja nicht, ob jemand das hat oder nicht. Ja, aber trotzdem, erstmal haben Stücke mit Wegsein. Jedenfalls gibt es jetzt keinen Grund, für die da drauf zu treten, glaube ich. Noch nicht.
Ja, aber wenn die die verkaufen, wenn es viele sind, dann sinkt der Preis natürlich auch ein bisschen.
Das sind vielleicht genau die.
Könnte sein. Über Bitcoins?
Ich hatte hier noch ein paar Themen von der letzten, die wir letzte Woche schon nicht behandelt haben. Wissen wir da mittlerweile irgendwas Neues drüber, oder wollen wir die anderen Sachen hier vorziehen?
Gitarre fällt aus, würde ich sagen. Roddy wollte was noch zu den Trust Zones von Arm erzählen. Das würde mich auch ein bisschen interessieren. Also wir erinnern uns, das iPhone S speichert angeblich die Fingerprint-Hashes oder was auch immer an diesen Arm Trust Zones und deswegen kommt man da wohl nicht ran.
Also das mit der Trust Zone von Arm ist schon ein bisschen älter. Irgendwie, das Paper war glaube ich aus dem Jahr 2009, was ich dazu gelesen habe. Das hatte in den letzten... Schauen wir uns in den Kommentaren jemand verlinkt. Und da dachte ich, da gucke ich mal rein. Man findet das aber auch so, wenn man da ein bisschen sucht.
Das war ich in der vorletzten Sendung oder so, ne?
Ne, in den Kommentaren hatte noch mal... oder was? Das war ein richtiges Paper. Jetzt müsste ich mal kurz gucken. Ich gucke mal eben nach, wie das hieß. Damit wir hier nicht so rumeiern. Das sag ich jetzt mal einfach so. Achso, ne, ich hab ja hier den ARM-Ordner. Das heißt, ARM Security Building a Secure System Using Trust Zone Technology. Und das haben sie als White Paper bezeichnet. Und zwar das Interessante ist, das hatten wir in der Diskussion um den ARM 64 ja schon mal angesprochen, ist, dass es also nicht nur verschiedene Exception Level hat, wo man irgendwie auf verschiedenen Sicherheitsniveaus irgendwie mit Hypervisor und haste nicht gesehen und User Space und Kernel Space und so weiter machen kann, sondern es gibt eben noch diese Trust Zone und diese Trust Zone ist quasi ein zweiter Betriebsmodus vom Prozessor. Was mal so ein fast so ein bisschen wie so ein Unterhypervisor ist. Allerdings ist es so, dass du in die Trust Zone wechseln kannst ohne den Exception Level zu wechseln, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Irgendwie über so eine Art, also über so eine Art besondere Trust Zone Exception wechselst du in einen sicheren Modus und jetzt kommt das eigentlich geile daran und zwar im Adressbus des ARM gibt es ein weiteres Bit, das Secure Modus Bit. Also du hast also nicht 32 Adressleitungen im 32 Bit Prozessor, sondern 33, beziehungsweise 65 statt 64, sodass du Peripherie anbinden kannst, die sagen kann, nur wenn das Secure Bit gesetzt ist, melde ich mich überhaupt auf den Bus. Also du hast also quasi zwei komplett getrennte Adresspages, auf denen irgendwas passiert.
Das ist noch mal so ein anderes Universum, aber hat der 64 Bit Prozessor also auch nicht 64 Bit Adressleitung wirklich?
Die brauchen die doch gar nicht.
Die haben bestimmt nur sowas wie...
Also das Paper ist aus der Zeit, wo sie nur von 32 Bit gesprochen haben. Also sie werden dieses eine Secure Bit trotzdem haben, auch wenn sie vielleicht nicht die vollen 64 Bit Adressleitungen tatsächlich intern zur Verfügung stellen. Aber es ging halt auch darum, dass du halt IP, also dieses ganze zusatzgedrahte Zeug... Du kaufst ja selten einen ARM-Chip direkt so, wie er ist, und löst es dann irgendwas außen rum, sondern du hast ja immer diesen ARM IP-Core, um den du dann andere IP-Module drum steckst, die teilweise Sicherheitsfunktionen haben. Da ist nix mehr, die haben wir platt gemacht. Das interessante ist, dass sie dieses Bit tatsächlich durch sämtliche Caches mitschleppen und eben aber auch über die Address Translation, die du brauchst, um eine Memory-Memory zu machen. Das ist völlig abstrus irgendwie. Du kannst halt dann so Sachen sagen wie der Secure-Modus kann auch auf einen normalen Speicher zugreifen, aber der nicht Secure-Modus kann halt nicht auf den Secure-Speicher oder Adressraum zugreifen.
Managements haben wir hier. Jetzt haben wir ein Bit mehr, das ist ja genauso wie, es gibt ja auch im IP-Header ein Evil Bit, da gibt es einen RFC dafür. Was man hier vielleicht zu setzen hat, wenn man böse ist, damit die Firewalls das leichter entdecken können. Wie läuft denn das mit der Software? Ich muss ja auch im Secure-Modus eine Software laufen lassen können. Diese Software muss ich da auch hin tun können und die möchte ich vielleicht auch gerne updaten können. Das heißt, was hindert mich jetzt daran, sozusagen mir einen Trojaner zu bauen, den ich über die Update-Funktion hinbaue, der dann irgendwie im Secure-Modus läuft und dann doch wieder an die Daten rankommt, an den ich eigentlich nicht rankommen soll? Wo ist da die Sicherheitsmechanismus da drin?
Die Idee ist, dass der Teil, der im Secure-Modus läuft an Software, auch so eine Art Hypervisor ist, den du nicht mehr updatest, wenn er einmal drin ist. Also der hoffentlich dann auch sicher ist, beziehungsweise, dass du über Prüf-Summen den Update des Secure-Modus-Speichers halt entsprechend sicher hast, dass das nicht aufgemacht wird. Gut, dass es trotzdem immer wieder aufgemacht wird, ist eine andere Geschichte, aber sie bauen da halt eine andere Art von Sicherheit ein. Das heißt, du kannst im nicht Secure-Modus im Prinzip dem Application Programmer, der jetzt nicht das Betriebssystem programmiert, sondern die Applikationen, die da drauflaufen, vollen Debugger hinstellen, der irgendwie alles kann und trotzdem kann dieser Debugger aber nicht in den Secure-Modus reingucken. Und kann dementsprechend halt auch keine Secure-Hardware auf die zugreifen. Und jetzt ist die Vermutung natürlich, dass Apple dieses Fingerabdrucklesen in diesem Trust-Zone-Secure-Modus macht. Und möglicherweise auch relativ viel Speicher dort verbraten kann, um dieses Zeug irgendwie zu speichern. Also ich bin ja nach wie vor der Meinung, dass sie wahrscheinlich komplette Bilder von den gesendten Abdrücken speichern, aber da bin ich so ein bisschen alleine mit der Einschätzung.
Nicht ja jedes Mal wieder evaluieren, das ist ja jedes Mal ihre Voodoo machen, die wieder auszurechnen.
Ja, aber wir reden hier von dem schnellsten Armchip, den du momentan auf dem Markt kaufen kannst. Und mit dem kannst du natürlich entsprechend gute Algorithmen rechnen, um eine Bilderkennung zu machen. Und die Bilderkennung wird umso besser, je mehr Daten du hast und je unverfälschter sie sind. Dementsprechend willst du eigentlich die Bilddaten im Original haben. Um damit ordentlich rechnen zu können.
Du kannst ja Non-Lossy komprimieren.
Ja, das kannst du tun, aber...
Die Punkte, die du schon erkannt hast, die Punkte, an denen du dich orientierst, die kannst du ja schon rausarbeiten. Das machst du ja jedes Mal sonst immer dieselbe Arbeit immer wieder.
Ja, aber wie ich gesagt habe...
Mit den selben Daten ist ja Quack.
Wie ich gesagt habe, je früher du deine Daten reduzierst, und zwar lossy, umso schlechter funktioniert hinterher die Erkennung. Das heißt, du wirst sie nähergut Non-Lossy, kannst du sie natürlich komprimieren. JPEG ist natürlich lossy.
Ja, aber mir geht es ja darum, dass ich mir nicht jedes Mal wieder die Rechenarbeit, die ohnehin jedes Mal mache, immer wieder machen muss. Ich will ja nur noch vom Prinzip vergleichen. Ich möchte sozusagen... Das ist ja das, was sie vom Prinzip machen. Sie können ja nicht den Daumenabdruck 100% genau machen, weil du kriegst ihn ja nie 100% genau wieder auf dieselbe Stelle gelegt und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen müssen sie ja eh da so ein bisschen Fuzzy-Algorithmen drin haben, die sagen, naja, sieht noch okay aus. So, und das heißt, das kann man doch... Da kann man doch seinen Datenstand durchaus redaktieren. Weil, das funktioniert alles mit ganz anders.
Das wissen wir zumindest nicht. Apple hat zum Beispiel gesagt, sie speichern irgendwelche Hashes ab, also nicht Fingerprints direkt.
Ja, aber Hashes haben halt so diese Eigenschaft, also richtige kryptographische Hashe. Es ist klar, ich ändere ein Bit und der Hash ändert sich komplett. Mit sowas kannst du natürlich nicht arbeiten, wenn du so ein Merkmal hast, wo du eine bestimmte Wahrscheinlichkeit nur angeben kannst, dass das das Merkmal ist, was du mal gelernt hast. Also du hast halt eine bestimmte Wahrscheinlichkeit, es ist das Merkmal. Und du hast eine bestimmte Wahrscheinlichkeit, das ist nicht das Merkmal. Und diese beiden Gaußglockenkurven müssen halt möglichst weit auseinander sein, damit die Überschneidung dieser Gaußkurven klein ist, weil an der Stelle machst du halt den Fehler. Und nochmal, also je mehr Daten du hast, desto besser kannst du einschätzen, ob es das jetzt war oder nicht. Und deswegen willst du so wenig wie möglich wegwerfen. Das ist meine Einschätzung von der Sache.
Vielleicht liegt auch total falsch.
Also die Management Summary war, Trust Zone ist halt bis in die Hardware. Die Hardware hat halt dieses eine Bit, was da an diesem Bus dranhängt und wo gewisse Teile halt von der Peripherie, die um den Arm drumrum sind, halt nur von der Trust Zone zu adressieren sind, weil wenn das Bit nicht gesetzt ist, schalten die sich halt auf Durchlauf. Und das fand ich ein sehr interessantes Konzept, muss ich sagen. So weit so gut. War das verständlich? Ja, ne.
Hattest du jetzt nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, ist das jetzt alles in Ordnung oder nicht?
Alles super, das hast du gerade gesagt. Du hast die Zusammenfassung verpasst am Ende.
Die Zusammenfassung.
Die möchte ich jetzt von dir garantieren haben, dass sie secure ist.
Die Zusammenfassung der Zusammenfassung.
Ja, also secure ist ja nix. Das ist ja immer eine Frage, wie viel Aufwand betreibe ich, und dann kriege ich alles gehackt. Aber sagen wir mal so, sie machen in dem White Paper halt dieses Beispiel, also sie haben, wie nennen sie es, nennen es ein Hack Attack, ein Shack Attack und ein Lab Attack. Der Hack Attack ist dieses reine Software Ding, jemand findet eine Software-Lücke und ohne das Device irgendwie anzufassen, nutzt er die aus und bekommt Zugriff aufs Device. Der sogenannte Shack Attack ist so, dieser kleine Hardware-Shack um die Ecke, der immerhin in der Lage ist, das Teil zu zerlegen und irgendwo einen JTAG-Adapter ranzuklemmen und mal zu gucken auf der Debuggen-Netzstelle, was geht denn so? Dann gibt es noch den Lab Attack, wo du anfängst, die Chips auseinanderzusägen und zu gucken, wo du machen kannst. Sie sagen halt, diese klassischen alten Nokia-Fone, wenn du die aufgeschraubt hast und den Debug-Stecker angesteckt hast, hat dir das Telefon gehört. Da gab es keine weitere Sicherheit mehr. Sie sagen, gegen diesen Shack Attack, also jemand macht das Telefon auf und klemmt sich an die Debug-Schnittstelle dran. Dagegen ist Trust Zone immer noch sicher. Das ist das, was sie behaupten. Nee, das ist ja alles auf dem Die.
Du musst schon mit einer CNC-Fräse das richtig runterfräsen.
Das sind Leitringen auf dem...
Es geht nicht an extern angeschlossenen Hardware, sondern das ist ja alles da auf dem armen Daim mit drauf, weil es ja SoC ist und deswegen verstehe.
Genau, darum geht's. Keine Ahnung, du kannst sicherlich auch dieses entsprechende Signal auf einem Pin nach außen führen, aber ich fürchte, dann ist es relativ einfach, die Sache... Ja, das ist albern. Genau, so kann man das sagen.
Sagen wir so, die Angriffszenarien sind alle viel komplizierter, als wenn sie sich einfach meinen Fingerabdruck besorgen würden.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Der Starbucks-Angriff ist schon der einfachste momentan. Es sei denn, da gibt es überhaupt eine einfache Variante.
Der Starbucks-Angriff ist in dem Sinne ja nicht so einfach, weil dazu muss der halt dein Telefon haben. Es ging ja auch darum, was sie verändern wollten, wenn irgendwann mal ein Bug im iPhone ist. Wie wir ja schon hatten, wurden ja die Telefone auch schon über den Aufruf einer Webseite gejailbreakt. Wenn man über die gleiche Methode nicht nur das Telefon jailbreakt, sondern auch noch die Fingerabdrücke ausliest, das galiert der Starbucks nicht so gut. Deswegen brauchten die halt Trust Zone.
Das ist natürlich eine Frage, was für ein Angriffsszenario hat man. Klar, wenn du sagst, jemand jailbreakt dir durch eine Malware das Telefon und liest den Fingerabdruck raus, okay, dann muss man sich natürlich fragen, aber was will er mit dem Fingerabdruck? Was anderes ist, jemand nimmt dir auf der Party das Glas weg und hat dann deinen Fingerabdruck. Und kommt eine Stunde später mit dem entsprechenden Fingerabdruck und macht dir das Telefon auf.
Aber stell dir einfach vor, es gibt irgendwann mal noch andere Geräte, die das auch mit dem Fingerprint machen und nicht nur Apple. Und wenn dann der Attack kommt, dass Hacker hat von 20 Telefonen 20 Millionen Telefonen den Fingerprint ausgelesen und damit irgendwelche anderen Geräte halt authentifiziert, das ist schon nicht so cool. Also das wollte Apple wahrscheinlich vermeiden und deswegen haben sie halt so, ich weiß nicht wie viel Aufwand die hatten, aber zumindest ein bisschen mehr Aufwand als wenn sie es nicht gemacht hätten. Und die Schlagzeile wollten sie halt vermeiden.
Das sehe ich schon ein und ich denke, das ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht so einfach, es sei denn, es findet tatsächlich jemand eine Lücke in dem ganzen Scheiß und schafft es da irgendwie ranzukommen. Aber so, ich meine so rein vom Sicherheitstechnischen, aber darüber haben wir ja schon geredet, ist ja jetzt der Fingerabdruck kein Passwort. Also das ist so irgendwie, insofern.
Ich will auch noch eins. Ich hab das genau gesehen.
Die war sehr lecker übrigens.
Wie, hast du jetzt alles aufgegessen, Roddy?
Noch mehr Schoki.
Ich hab nur drei gegessen von den Dinger.
Dann hab ich den Rest gegessen, ja, war meine Schuld.
Willst du noch mehr?
Dinge, die ich nicht hören will.
Ach komm Clemens, du willst gar keine Schokolade.
Die Freuden des Remote-Arbeitens.
Also wir haben jetzt hier schon irgendwie unsere drei Stunden locker durchgerockt. Ich konnte auch gerade Ableton Live davon abhalten, dich nicht mehr aufzunehmen. Clemens, aber ich kam gerade rechtzeitig noch dazwischen. Heldenhaft hab ich mich in die Bresche geworfen. Ich würd dir jetzt auch gern noch ein Bierchen durchreichen, aber...
Remote-Bier-Protokoll arbeiten wir schon seit längerem dran in der ITF.
Schwierig, schwierig.
Du weißt doch, IMIT-Pod.
Ich hatte noch mal kurz eine Nachfrage. Hatte das iPod eher eigentlich... Hat das eigentlich dieses WLAN 802AC?
Nein, das hat nur diesen Mimo-Kram. Und damit über das normale Enden überhaupt erst mal doppelte Performance. Das ist überhaupt das erste Mal doppelte Antennengeschichten da drin.
Es macht auch noch nicht so viel Sinn für diese Dinger. Der Grund, warum man das in Laptops einbaut, ist, weil man bei Laptops eben noch massiv Filtransfer macht zu einem lokalen Fileserver. Diese anderen Dinger reden ja in der Hauptsache, ich sag mal, in der Hauptsache mit dem Internet. Oder das Schlimmste, was sie mal machen, ist, dass sie sich ein Filmchen ziehen live von deinem Laptop oder irgendwie sowas über Apple Content Sharing.
Ja, die haben auch relativ flangsam.
Also das heißt, diese Geschichte, wo du jetzt durch die Luft richtig mal ordentlich Bits knallen willst, brauchst du eigentlich nur, wenn du jetzt Files durch die Gegend transportierst auf dem Laptop. Und da es ja keine Files gibt auf diesen mobilen Dingern, werden wir das auch noch eine Weile nicht sehen.
Der Flash-Speicher ist auch relativ langsam. Also auf diesen Geräten.
Ja, da wird wahrscheinlich der nettschneller sein als der Flash-Speicher, könnte sein.
Möglicherweise, ja. Was ich noch erwähnen könnte, wäre das Headset, was ich heute hier das erste Mal trage.
Ja, wie war's?
Ja, super.
Warum? Ist es besser, ist es schlechter?
Also es handelt sich um das Bayer Dynamics DT-797. Das ist so wie diese großen Kopfhörer nur mit dem Mikrofon dran. Und es trägt sich so wie die großen Kopfhörer sehr angenehm, weil es halt die großen, fetten Muscheln hat und viel Auflageplatzfläche, die nicht auf dem Ohr ist und so.
Aber wird auch schön warm deine Rübe dadurch, oder?
Ja, aber wird sie bei den anderen auch, also insofern. Warm wird's eh.
Ja, Roddy hat jetzt sozusagen sein eigenes Besteck, wenn er zum Podcasten geht.
Das eigene Fixer-Besteck?
Jaja, ich warte noch drauf, bis er mit so Geigenkästen ankommt.
Ich hab ja die Sennheiser HD 380 oder so, die haben ja auch so große Muscheln irgendwie, die rund ums Ohr drum sitzen und nicht so aufs Ohr draufdrücken, weil die drücken schon noch ein bisschen drauf, oder? So minimal?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Da passt schon ein ganzes Ohr rein.
Nein, da hast du kleine Ohren.
Naja, was soll ich dazu sagen? Da passt schon ein Ohr rein.
Ja, ich find schon, dass es so ein bisschen draufdrückt. Und bei meinen Sennheisern, das ist auch eher größer und ist so drumrum, aber es hat halt kein Mikro.
Willst du mir noch nicht ernsthaft sagen, dass die Kopfhörer, die du aufhast, irgendwo direkt auf dein Ohr draufdrücken?
Doch.
Wo denn?
Na direkt?
Nein, die drücken am Ohr vorbei.
Ja, aber sie berühren das Ohr noch, wenn es nur außen ist, ist doch egal.
Ja, aber da drücken sie doch nicht. Du meinst, du hast so einen Kantendruck?
Ja, genau, so könnte man es sagen.
Der randt immer auch immer rum.
Und Roddy hat jetzt bestimmt keinen Kantendruck mehr.
Ich hab keinen Kantendruck.
Das ist ja beruhigend.
Und Roddy, was hat der Spaß gekostet?
Ich wollte dich jetzt nochmal fragen, was kostet der Spaß?
Also das ist so, die kosten ungefähr so viel wie die anderen.
Wie viel, Roddy?
Kannst du das in Zahlen ausdrücken bitte?
Ja, was weiß ich was die anderen kosten.
Wenn man berücksichtigt, dass bei den anderen kein Kabel dabei ist und man das extra kaufen muss, dann sind die sogar glaube ich noch 20 billiger oder so.
Wie viel?
270, 250?
Irgendwie sowas.
Du hast jetzt für 250 Kopfhörer geholt, weil du die hier bei Timmer alle zwei Wochen nutzen willst?
Wegen des Kantendrucks.
Nee, ich werd die auch zu Hause benutzen, so ist es nicht.
Aber zum Podcast oder nur zur Musik hören?
Das ist auch gut zum Telefonieren im Übrigen.
Zum ja Skype-Persen.
Also jetzt wo ich hier so zumindest eine SIP-Klein Installation habe, die halbwegs stabil und einfach benutzbar ist, gehe ich dazu über, immer darüber zu telefonieren, damit ich meine Headset machen kann, weil es einfach geiler ist, als wenn man sich die ganze Zeit so eine Wurst ans Ohr drückt. Naja, so eine Hörerwurst, weißt du?
Wir drücken unsere Hörer nicht ans Ohr.
Naja, du weißt doch, wie das ist. Du hast halt die ganze Zeit eine Hand, du willst halt frei telefonieren können, du willst halt beide Hände frei haben.
Ja, aber eigentlich will man auch noch ohne Kabel haben.
Das ist die Pest von den meisten dieser Bluetooth-Headsets, wenn er da mit mal rumspielt. Ich hab ja auch dieses Bedürfnis, weil ich ja sehr viele remote mache und so. Es gibt ja diese tollen High-End Bluetooth-Headsets. Tim, du hattest mir auch mal ein Selene. Was war denn das nochmal? Das war Plantronics oder was? Nein, weiß ich nicht. Die haben alle die tollen...
Diese Teile mit diesen roten Dingern, warte ich mal auf, wo die Leute meinten, das Sound wäre so wie aus dem Klo. Du hattest doch mal ein so ein Ding hier.
Ja, pass mal auf. Der Knaller ist der, diese Dinger kannst du entweder in diesem Audio, ich höre jetzt mal Musikmodus betreiben, aber in dem Moment, wo du das scheiß Mikrofon anmachst, weil du jetzt zum Beispiel damit skypen willst oder sonst immer, fallen die in diesen Drecks-Telefon-Modus. Denn klingen die nämlich wirklich so wie aus dem Klo. Diese 3,1 Kilohertz, ja, la la la, wir wollen ja nur telefonieren, bla bla bla, Bluetooth. Und du kriegst die Dinger verrecken, nicht dazu, dass du dir auf dem Kopfhörer mit diesem Stereo-Audio-Sound, den du so aus einem Laptop oder so ausrottest, oder aus einem iPhone, dass du darüber telefonieren kannst. Entweder sind sie in diesem rottigen Telefon- Blechbüchsen-Modus oder wir hören Musik. Aber beides geht nicht. Das finde ich sehr, sehr ärgerlich. Wir prangern das an.
Naja, das mit dem Telefonieren, das wird sich eh nicht durchsetzen.
FaceTime Audio sag ich mal.
Ich muss jetzt gleich mal wieder ein bisschen Holz nachlegen.
So, wer hat denn hier diesen anderen Clem Wim da noch draufgeschrieben?
Ich glaube, da ist einiges vom Huckel dabei.
Mit dem Ring? Ja, das muss Huckel dann selber vertreten.
Aber sah interessant aus, aber ich glaube, es ist nur ein Gimmick, oder?
So, das haben wir nämlich schon. Dann sind wir nämlich jetzt schon fast durch. Jetzt haben wir eigentlich nur noch E-Mail.
Das mit der ASCII-WWDC, da könnte ich auch eine Kleinigkeit zu sagen. Und zwar hat sich da jemand die Mühe gemacht, irgendwie ein Tool zu schreiben, das aus den WWDC-Videos von Apple die Untertitel rausliest. Und die dann auf einer Webseite einfach nur als Klartext untereinander tut. Und dann kannst du eben auf dem Ding ist es halt plötzlich durchsuchbar.
Was ich ja bei den Apple-Videos noch nicht verstehe, ist, warum sich da ein, hat sich teilweise eine Minute lang das Bild nicht, aber sie machen trotzdem ein Video draus. Also eigentlich könnten sie doch so einen Quicktime-Bilderslide-Dings irgendwie runterladbar machen, wäre dann wahrscheinlich nur an 50 Dülse groß.
Keine Ahnung.
Na, wenn der Videokompressor gut ist, ist es dann auch an 50 Dülse so groß. Ich glaub, das ist nicht so ihr Problem.
Ja, eigentlich wollte man irgendwie mal so ein Format haben. Du hast nur Audio plus die Information, wann im PDF das nächste Slide angeschaltet werden soll. Das wär mal interessant.
PDF mit Audio einfach.
Es gibt halt immer die PDFs dazu. Und ich meine, was anderes als die PDFs, siehst du im Video auch nicht. Außer, dass sie jetzt mal zwischen den Slides Transitions sind irgendeiner Art. Gut, manchmal ist auch so ein bisschen Demo noch dabei.
Jetzt drück doch mal auf eins drauf, Timmer hier. Timmer ist jetzt gerade bei asciiwwdc.com und hat jetzt mal draufgedrückt. Das ist ja einfach der Text hintereinander weg.
Genau, also Apple transkribiert die Dinge im Nachhinein. Und man kann das halt dann mit Untertiteln gucken.
Meinst du nicht, dass sie von dem Typ natürlich, also das ist doch fix, was die da erzählen? Dann kriegen sie doch einfach gleich sein Paper, oder? Nee, der macht doch vorher seine Rede, der schreibt das doch auf. Da üben die bestimmt wochenlang, was die da erzählen.
Das ist nicht abgelesen.
Nein, das ist nicht abgelesen.
Die Slides sind immer gut vorbereitet.
Nee, nie und immer ist das abgelesen. Nie und immer ist das abgelesen. Das kannst du komplett backen.
Das ist auch schon. Also abgelesen wäre es nicht. Es versucht sich zu merken, aber...
Nein, das ist einfach gut trainiert. Wenn du deinen Vortrag zwei, drei Mal übst...
Ja, aber dann ist das doch auch immer das Gleiche, was sie erzählen.
Ja, aber es ist ein Unterschied, ob du abliest oder ob du das frei erzählst. Da kommt immer was anderes bei raus. Das ist keine Diktion, einfach eine andere.
Also das eigentlich Interessante an dieser ASCII-WWDC ist halt, dass es jetzt durchsuchbar ist. Also wenn du jetzt... Der hat doch was erzählt. Das findest du nicht im PDF.
Ja, aber wo ist die Zeitmarke? Wo kann man dann direkt ins Video klicken? Ist doch alles Leben.
Jeder, wer's Movie, wer's Subscene Generator ist besser.
Also das ist schon mal ganz nett, aber eigentlich naja, wir bauen das alles im Pottler auf einer.
Ja, ja, da ist noch Raum für Verbesserungen. Okay, seh ich ein.
Aber sicherlich hilfreich für jemanden, der jetzt mal sucht irgendwie, wo wurde Lalalala erwähnt und so.
Diese Uhr, die du da von dem Huckel da hast mit dem Ring, was er in zwei Wochen erzählen wird, ja, die kostet 235 Dollar. Können ja voll knicken.
Ja, wollte ich eigentlich schon vor zwei Wochen erzählen, aber ja, vielleicht hören wir davon noch.
Du meinst, das, was du da hingeschrieben hast?
Ja, ich hab's nur kurz draufgeschrieben, mal zur Erwähnung. Ich hab ja neulich was erzählt über Exim, wo ich gleich wieder angefeindet, warum ich den Post fixen benutze. Post fix, danke. Ich benutze Exim und da gab's jetzt seit langer, langer Zeit mal wieder ein Major Update mit vielen tollen Features. Aber auf die geh ich jetzt um die Uhrzeit nicht mehr ein. Dazu müssen wir uns eh mal unterhalten, erstmal, was das für Features sind, und dann kann man auch erklären, warum die toll sind. Aber für die Leute, die irgendwo noch ein Exim rumzuliegen haben, es gibt jetzt 4-8-2, viel Spaß damit.
Apropos Mail, warum gibt's im iPhone, im iOS 7, immer noch keinen Mail-Filter, also keinen Spam-Filter? Jetzt sagt man nicht, den braucht man nicht, weil das macht man auf dem Server, dann können sie ja den Spam-Filter auf dem Desktop-Mail auch entfernen. Haben sie aber nicht. Und ich meine, wenn das iPhone jetzt schon schneller ist, das neueste wie ein Laptop von 2009 oder 10 oder wie auch immer, und Mail-Spam-Filter gibt's auf dem Mail-Programm, auf dem Desktop schon seit, keine Ahnung, bestimmt 10 Jahre oder 8 oder weiß nicht wie lange?
Also ich hab das auf einer Powerbook G3 mit 400 MHz gehabt. Und ich hätte das eigentlich gerne auch schon auf dem iPhone 1 mit 400 MHz gehabt. Ja, jetzt sind wir irgendwo bei fast 2 GHz und 64 Bit. Und es gibt immer noch keinen Spam-Filter.
Also so teuer ist das übrigens nicht. Ja, diese Dinger, klar, die können mal einen Rechner ins Schützen bringen, aber so ein Mail-Server, der also Mails für Hunderte von Leuten kriegt und dauernd von außen per SMTP zugeknallt wird. So ein iPhone hat ja keinen offenen SMTP-Port, sondern das kriegt ja nur Mails, die ohnehin nur für diesen User sind. Und da jetzt noch mal drauf zu gucken, ob einem das gefällt oder nicht.
Wir wollten ja nur das K.O.-Argument bringen, dass selbst wenn es viel Arbeit wäre, dass trotzdem das iPhone auch im Stande wäre. Und dass es keine Arbeit ist, wissen wir ja auch. Weil eigentlich, meine Mails kommen ja alle schon pregetagged vom Spam-Assassin. Ist ja nicht so, dass die das Tag nicht hätten. Er muss es nur noch auslesen und entsprechend wegsortieren. Und weil das ist immer, wenn ich meine Mail zuerst auf dem Phone lese, dann ist der ganze Spam halt noch da. Wenn ich es auf dem Laptop mache, dann wird es schön wegsortiert. Und das ist, was noch am meisten nervt, würde ich mal sagen.
Tja, wir prangern das an.
Wir prangern das an. Aber sonst, denke ich, können wir hier mal ein Ende finden, oder? Dann leiten wir doch mal hier das Ende ein. Oh Gott, ich bin müde, ihr auch. Ihr seid alle müde, ihr dürft ja endlich einschlafen. Ist das nicht schön?